We might be too hard to talk pretty high.
This is a bad way to start a podcast,
but yet we do it this way.
Every time you guys talk about that stuff,
sometimes it takes about
15 minutes to recover.
Like once, once the first wave hits you,
you know what she wants from this wall.
And that explained that commercial.
It's kind of explains, yeah,
explains why they ramble. Uh, this,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you as always by
ANA [inaudible] dot com.
I'll just leave this brief.
Go there for all things awesome and
nutritious and healthy. That's it. Music,
codenamed Rogan, and you'll save
10% off any and all supplements.
We got kettle bells, Alpha brains. We've
got battle ropes where you ass bitch.
So go down there, get some hemp
protein and you know what to do.
You use the code name Rogan
and you'll save 10% off any.
And all supplements were also brought
to you today by hover and hover is,
um,
a hover is a domain name company that's a,
that's owned by the same
people that own ting. And, uh,
we're big fans of Ting Ting became uh,
one of the few podcast
sponsors that we have. And uh,
when they told us they were trying to
use their non evil company approach
towards domain name sales,
we thought that was a great idea
is Yoshi loves banana bread.com.
Has Anybody got that?
You know what somebody did somebody,
you know what I was joking around when
day about suck my cock fatty.com somebody
took that and registered it and made a
mirror of my website.
So now if you go to suck my
cock fatty.com it's my website,
which is hilarious, but all that
could have been done through hover,
hover a offers a lot of a cool software
to use and they offer a lot of cool
things that are free like a
who is privacy protection, um,
sub domains,
a URL forwarding,
all that stuff that should be included
with the domain name management.
They include that for, it's
all that's all free. And uh,
I think that's just indicative of how
they are with Ting and just how they are
period.
If he goes to hover.com Rogan,
you will get a 10% off your domain name
registrations. Right? You dirty bitches.
Listen, Yo, she's here and David shows
here. We're going to get freaky with this.
Oh,
well Brian has a show a Thursday night
at the Improv with WHO's on that?
We got it.
Joey Diaz.
Duncan Trussell.
Brody Stevens. Uh, we might
have, oh, we have Yoshi.
Yoshi is going to be there.
Yoshi.
And we might even have Tiffany Haddish
and a couple of his nose nickname. No,
what's his name? Yo.
Shemale. Oh No, that's,
oh my goodness. This Wednesday
night, Yoshi will also
be with me at the Ice House. The Ice
House. Brian, will they be there as well?
Adam Hunter will be there. Ian
Edwards was, will be there. Who else?
Is there somebody else going to
someone else? Yoshi. N N
words. Uh, whatever bitch.
Oh No. Why would you do that? I
don't know. What'd you make up?
A famous, that'd be really
cool if he came to freak.
You're such a mass. Uh,
but, uh, anyway, that's a,
this one's in at 10 o'clock at the Ice
House. Someone else is coming. God Damn.
And I can't remember who it
is. Tony Hinchcliffe. No,
no, I dunno. Well I can't,
I can't remember it. So just
cue the music and rescue me.
Wilson experience try by day Joe
Rogan podcast by night all day.
It's not official
until the music starts that who did
that song? Brian did it. Oh, I'm sorry.
That garage band. This is a fucking
master. He's a garage band master.
It sucks because I hear it all the time
and like stupid TV shows and commercials
now. Like, like, like one of the rifts in
that song. Oh really? Yeah. And it's like,
ah, it's what the cause it's
a garage band riff. Yeah.
Like there's parts of it that are
just straight up from garage band.
I tweak that a little bit.
Yoshi male,
our friend Yoshi is
here. Hey Joe, what's up?
Yosh and brought his friend David Cho,
who insists on relentless asleep.
Relentlessly torturing Yoshi about,
uh, it's pretty fucking good at it.
His nickname, this is a strange
nickname, Yoshi. Yoshi male?
Yes. Why? Why would that,
why would they call you that?
Is there a story to go with this?
Well, for people who do know Yoshi,
they know that he used to work in the
porn business and his currency was porn.
Like if,
if you needed to get tickets to something,
like Yoshi knows a lot of athletes and,
and a rock stars and whatever,
and he's like, hey, you guys
want some porn? He's just,
he's always there with the box of porn.
And if you've gotten a
box of porn from Yoshi,
you know that sometimes he hide some.
That's true. Do you hide
it in there? Is it like
your way of just like letting
people get Ahold of it? So like,
people who wouldn't ordinarily watch it,
we're like, well, fuck it. I got the DVD.
No one's here but me.
Let's just throw this on right now.
What are you trying to do? I'm trying
to figure out what they're into. And uh,
he likes, you know, he likes it. He
likes to make people uncomfortable. No,
but you know what?
Sometimes even when they're angry,
I could tell it's a fake ingredient.
They really liked it. Ooh, really?
It'd be interesting to,
if you could have a cap camera set up
to see how long they watched it before
they turned it off. You
know, they're like, this is
disgusting. Get the lube out.
And there's still did a study a while
back where they took men who are
homophobic and they showed them,
uh, image, heard about this,
guys having sex and they showed
arousal. Oh, I'm really the opposite.
I heard that they got, uh, like,
like if a flight or fight response,
like they get really like
aggressive and angry. Really? Yeah.
What I read was that it was penile arousal
was the word that they, there was a,
uh,
a recognized arousal in the males
that were especially homophobic,
like especially angry about gay people
as much more common for them to actually
like Yoshi fighting off gay
thoughts like Yoshi gets aroused.
Thinking about a straight male watching.
What did that come from?
Oh, by the way, don't believe
everything you says. All right.
You told me if I'm laying
there. So I, so Yoshi,
you know, like everyone in here watches
porn, you watch, you jerk off to it.
But this, this was this guy's life.
So what, what gets this guy hard?
A guy who like a nine to five job watches
porn from morning till night, right?
Just asses Dicks,
penises and pussy just smashing together,
like over and over, over again. And a
lot of the times when I used to call him,
I'm like, Hey, Yo, you want to go get
dinner or something? He'd be like, no,
I gotta finish the tranny porn.
And it was a,
I always thought it was like he
was just fucking with me. Right.
But then he's like, it's not this
like niche thing. It's like huge.
It's our number one seller.
And it always has been. Yeah.
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, wow.
That's what I said. Okay.
This is something that people weren't,
they love this shit. Black trainee porn.
It's the hottest thing. Oh
wait, is this like any huge,
the biggest underground and it's huge.
And untalked about, that's crazy.
The number one seller. Even when I work
at the retail sale or in Seattle, um,
we have booth and at the end
of the month we do Talia,
which movies sold the most? Top 10. It's
always combination gay or trainings.
Whoa, that's fucking crazy. Female.
Is there, um, a lack of that? Well,
there's not a lack of that
stuff on the Internet.
It's not like they would
have to purchase it.
Like why are they purchasing
that more than anything else?
Is that what the demand is? The
Ma did. It's like a man is Madison
ever trainee love and dudes are there.
What do you think
it is? Because this is what
I think it is. It's so easy,
by the way.
I did.
It's really shocked me that we started
that whole podcast with training sites.
Oh, it's shocking to you. All right, go
ahead. Why not? Why is it shocking to me,
Yoshi male? Not Though we've been talking
about, you know, let's talk about,
you were talking about you don't worry
about it. Alright. So what is your,
my thing is,
it's just,
you know, if you think of the things
that we used to have to jack off to,
you know, we're a bit older, like the
Sears catalog and it was just, you know,
if there was someone at your
school that had got a blowjob,
like they were like the
hero, you know, it's like,
like now like eight year old kids are
giving each other blowjobs it's just
talking about Jim Norton. All right,
go ahead. No, I'm, I'm like, Yo,
she's a grown up adult male
that watches porn all day.
But think about like a regular kid who
just discovered the internet and his
first boner. Like he can already
watch anal and everything. So I think,
I think you do anal,
you get blowjobs,
you have sex with your girlfriend and
you're like 16 and you've already seen and
done everything. You're like, what's the
next thing? You know? That's what I think.
I Dunno, I might be wrong
on that, but you know, once,
okay,
I dunno, you're in that
business. What do you think?
Why do you think it's such a huge thing?
I have a friend in Boston,
professor of evolutionary biology,
but he, he did like a research, like full,
very popular body parts
and internet search.
This is according to 100 million
research, um, obvious one,
tit ass feet and penis according
to 100 million research by men.
And according to my friend it,
it's because we're interested in
all the different sexual cues.
It's doesn't make you a gay person.
I think it's part of our competitiveness
like guides, urinating, bathroom,
kind of look over the guy's penis. You
know, it's not a gay thing, I don't think.
Well,
the,
I think part of the idea is also that a
lot of people have these sexual thoughts
about men because they were imprinted
with some sort of sexual experience by a
man when they were young, whether it
was molestation or something like that.
Whatever it is, they had some weirdness
that happened with another boy.
And because of that they have, even though
they don't have homosexual thoughts,
they're not homosexual.
They stay can still get aroused by the
idea of men or by the idea of doing
something you're not supposed to do.
Looking at a guy's cock.
If you fucking shemale is that
gay? Yes. Check this one out.
Charities not as gay jerk off to
it. Is that gay? Check this out.
Uh, no, no, no, but it's questionable.
What does that, what do you show him?
Avn. There was a ton of these guys
or they look like a normal guy,
but they had the nicest tits
in the whole entire world.
And so like they would pull
up their tits up for girls.
They could just suck on them.
It looks like it.
God, the totally looks like,
yeah. Can that looks like like a,
like an older actor guy. Like a regular
looking dude with huge titties. Yeah. So,
but they were everywhere. It just normal
looking blogging here. Kevin Mcdermott.
It's like Dylan Mcdermott with giant tits.
That was amazing. Kathy's been naming.
What is that? Is that a new look?
Yeah. There's another one like Danny,
I forget his name is. Uh, do you
know who I'm talking about? Yoshi?
He's a short blond hair. I don't remember
the last day. And he's something,
he was another one. Short blonde
hair. Oh, that reminds me. Do you?
I got you a present when I was in
navy and I brought it for you. It's,
it kind of fits this conversation to
you, son of a bitch. What did have,
you can frame it maybe hanging out,
scared, openness. It's, what is this?
It's dudes with the hard
Dick's in their pants. Oh,
let me see if you think you're funny.
Is that what it supposed to be?
Funny or underwear? Why you paid money
for this? You really wanted that.
This is one of those things.
Oh, well, if you don't
want it, I'll take it.
I bought it for you drunk the next day.
I was like, why did I buy this
roadshow is silly bitch. That was why,
but it's good artwork. He was aroused by
it. Yeah. He was around, I guess he was.
I got a little tingle right in.
They're looking at, if you're not,
he really wanted it for himself, but
while he was purchasing, he's like,
this is from my friend Joe, so it
takes the gayness away from him. Yeah.
If you're gay and you saw
that, you'd be psyched. Yeah.
That's how I thought it was funny.
I thought it was like that
gangster fag shit back in the day.
Got Joe will think this is hilarious.
Do you remember that there was a wrap
burned named Gangsta fag and
he had like, uh, all these uh,
Gangsta rap songs about
having sex with dude.
This shit's huge too. Yeah. In New York.
Have you seen it? Like, no, like homo now?
Yeah.
Like it's like super hardcore gangsters,
but then they like look like gangsters,
but they like wear pink and I forgot
what the movement is called, but it's in,
you see it a lot in New York.
Wow.
It's like they're on the subway just
like making out and they're like,
what the fuck you looking at?
And they're like, Holy Shit.
Gangster gay people. I
like it. I'm into it. Yeah.
We need another wrinkle in this society.
There it is.
Yeah.
What we're looking at for the folks
listening on Itunes, this is two,
it's a famous photo of to look,
they'd look Latino gentlemen was tape
Fletcher and gang tattoos and they're in
the tub together. Naked. No, no biggie.
Just totally not gay, just alive today.
Apparently that's in the Latino
community. In prison. It's a big thing.
It's gay for the stay for this day that
a lot of dudes gay when they're inside
and then when they get outside it's
like just shut up about it. Wow. Yeah.
Well I want to ask you
about that because you,
you do all the UFC stuff like
sometimes, you know. Okay,
so UFC starts right. And it was
like tank Abbott. There was like,
it was more like street fighter back then
there was like a sumo guy with like a
boxer and then at some point it all
went straight to like grappling. Right.
So on any given UFC fight,
if you just walk into the room,
all the fights playing, most of the
fights end up on the floor. Right?
A lot of them do. Yeah. Less
now I think then then more,
right. And then they're
wearing the, uh, you know,
the tight short shorts with a bone or
bulges and there is a lot of 69 going on.
There's a lot of like head to crotch
grinding. It looks very homoerotic.
You could if you were in and
two gay dudes and viewer in to dudes,
especially if you were an athletic dudes,
I would totally see how you
could see, uh, two men grappling,
especially bare chest to bare chest as
being a homoerotic and just as you there,
I mean people, but it's really
based upon your sexual preference.
If you're into that. Yeah, you
would think that's homoerotic,
but if you're not, it's not, you know
what I'm saying? If you're not gay,
it's just two dudes fighting. Right.
If you are gay, you'd be psyched.
Maybe you can enjoy it on another
level. Like you, it would be like,
not just fighting,
but fighting with like too hot dudes that
you're like really getting excited by
it. So you're getting excited by the fight
itself and you get excited by the fact
that you would like to suck both
their cocks after it's over.
Thank them for the show.
Yeah. I mean, you know,
sometimes you know this move at the
Strip club when you go and the girl like
gives you a simulated blowjob,
like she's blowing your budget
using the top of her head. Yeah,
I seen that in the UFC move,
like the guys like grinding his forehead
on the guy's crotch it. I'm like,
Oh fuck a stripper just did
that to me. Yeah, the head job,
you wouldn't want that if you
had a big heart cup on though.
It doesn't feel as good. You want
like sweat pants. That's true.
I knew it dude.
Who used to take a those nylon sweat
pants and you know the nylon sweatpants.
That dude's used to wear the joggers
back in the nineties remember those blue
nylon sweatpants people used to wear?
He took those and he sanded it with
thousand grit sandpaper and the crotch.
Who would get it?
Like he could hold it up to the light
and see his fingers and then he would
squirt lube.
He's shaved his cock and ball.
Complete complete shave or like
where the store is going to score it.
Lube all over himself,
put his sweatpants on and then he would
go to the Strip club and it was called
shooting. Who goes shooting. Oh.
And the girls would sit down and we give
him a lap dance and essentially he's
wearing a condom. Wow. How can advance,
I said, that's pretty clever.
You know, he's a very smart guy.
I used to live at the Strip club pretty
much in Vegas and nobody figured that
out there. Like me and my
friend Harry, when we'd go,
we'd take our genes off and
like put on sweatpants. Right.
Someone new to our group would be like,
what are you guys doing? We're like, dude,
we're about to get lap dances, but this,
this takes that to the whole other level.
Dude brought out grinding down.
That's fucking awesome.
Without sandpaper to the point where
the shit was like almost transparent.
He was using like 1500 grit,
which is like what you would use to
gently clean off the shaft of a pool cue.
You know what,
I'm that kind of dust,
just a slight level of dust
every [inaudible] basis.
This is so amazing. He, uh,
he wore that shit down where he could
get his fingers so he could see his
fingers in the light.
That's when he knew,
like he was technically still
close with was this guy,
this guy's name happened to
be Yoshi [inaudible] clever.
This guy was a very smart dude. I
won't give his name, but uh, he, uh,
it's like, and it's imperative that
you shave the cock and balls. She goes,
you want to have no hair,
no hair anywhere. Yeah.
Like an old technique to everything.
It's fantastic. And then he's like,
then you go Astroglide but then one time,
I guess he put on too much Astroglide
and a girl got on his lap, but she goes,
what the fuck the fuck is this? And
he was like, Oh yeah, I'm sorry.
She was, what are you doing? What are
you doing? I couldn't believe that just,
and I said, he got caught. He was
horrified. Please. Well, you know,
he basically took it too far.
He wasn't,
he just wearing the nylon and you got
the lube on underneath and she really
probably can't tell at first,
but he like had a puddle in his pants.
He tried to get crafty,
but he's tried to make a monument
to this guy every strip club.
Well for a long time.
Like he goes when he had his own business
and he was really dedicated to his
business, very hard on paper business.
He was selling shooting pants.
He uh, he, he had this business and so
he didn't have any time for, for dating.
So what he would do is he would go and
work all fucking day on his own business.
Then he would eat dinner,
he would order, take out,
then he would go to the Strip club and
his shooting pants and he would have the
ritual get one off and
then he'd go back home.
And that's what he would do every day,
whenever you want, whenever you want it.
And that was how he avoided relationships.
For the longest time. I would just go,
he would go shoot it cause he was just,
he had a few bad relationships and he
got fucked over. What does it checks?
He was in his 30s smart
guy and he just was like,
he was very logical to his approach to
solving problems. Where's he at now?
I haven't talked to him in a long time.
I don't know. Can I ask you a question?
Sure.
So I just walked in here and you guys
have all these sex at dawn books and like
I read that too, cause I'm interested
in human sexuality and all that stuff,
especially the shemale stuff.
So when I look at you,
I see like the last of
a dying breed of man,
like sort of like the intellectual jock.
Like you're like,
you're like a pretty big guy that
can beat the shit out of people,
but you're also like,
well read intelligent.
So what is your whole take on all
this? Like do you, are you married?
Do you have a girlfriend? I'm
married. Oh you are? I'm married.
I have kids and everything. I have
the whole deal. That's, you know,
it is crazy.
And we are for a long time.
I've been married for quite a
few years now. But for me, um,
the, the difference that happens when
you, uh, when you have kids, right,
is so hard to wrap your head around.
Like for anybody that's not
married and doesn't have kids.
Once you have like a little,
you a great day running around like the
love that you have for them is so it's
really, you could never imagine
that it would even be possible.
So it's a real mind fuck went.
How old are your kids?
I have a 16 year old stepdaughter.
I have a four year old and a two year old.
Well the fours,
almost five the two songs, three
pretty major. Unbelievably fascinating.
And cupcake over here. Who's about 30
Oh, so when I hear, when I hear it,
you're like, okay, here's like
the married path with like kids.
And then here's the other
path with the shooting pants.
Like I aimed more towards the shirt and
pants. You know what man? Shooting pants.
If the whole deal is finding
a compatible person, right?
If you don't find a compatible person,
you find somebody wants to fight all
the time, find someone to test you,
find someone who's not
at peace themselves,
you're going to have fucking problems.
Can always find something wrong with
people. Yeah. But as a, you know,
a man who probably gets hit on by chicks,
the time those fucking
ring girls are super smoking hot. Like
I mean, how do you deal with that?
Jerk off, keep it together, do your best.
I know a great guy that
has immense collection of
shemale porn that I could hook
you up
with.
The idea of caring hard porn is
so ridiculous these days with the,
all the websites. It does the industry
frown upon the websites. They look at it.
Other people look at,
do you know he's told me laying,
do you know what the uh,
that there's still,
they still print video
cassettes and like the VHS,
like I don't know anyone who buys
porn except stuff for myself.
But for in general, I don't know one
person who ever buys pornography,
like DVDs even has like a porn
pass or any of that stuff.
And so Yoshi educated me
that he said that the last,
the thing that keeps this business
alive is people like 50 and over.
All pervert. Yeah. They're
scared to use computers.
So they still go to the store and they
buy DVDs and VHS tapes and then once
their debt
dead,
then this business will be dead.
So the old perverts who just stuck
with their ways, they have this way,
they liked the remote control to liked
to be able to sit there on the bed.
There are also prayed the government
might get them, they're probably right.
You know, because there's no, you know,
there's nothing of it on their computer.
So
cause you're,
you're trusting the companies that every
one of those girls are 18 and older.
It's a funny thing man. But if someone
who is in a high position of power,
like say a political person and they
found that they had tranny porn at their
house, even though it's
totally legal. Right.
And even know you're saying
it's the biggest market.
So it represents a lot of human beings
that are into that stuff. You'd be done,
right? Yeah, for sure. How
weird is that? Why, why is,
how weird is it that we give a fuck about,
like Jimmy Norton is a very good friend
of mine. I love that. I love that guy.
I don't care that he jerks
off to trainings at all.
It doesn't bother me that
he's had training experiences.
It's Hilarious when he tells you about it,
like the,
the fact that you would judge what
tweaks someone sexually wants,
what the heart wants.
But it's complete like that.
It's a weird sort of homophobia
that still accepted. It's,
it's a weird sort of prejudice that's
still accepted that your sexual preference
and even if you're a nice person,
even though you're nice and you
know you're intelligent, we'll,
we'll judge you based on whether or
not you jerk off to dudes with dicks or
dudes or looks like chicks with dicks.
I remember even lady the late eighties
that stolen or didn't want to have
interracial tapes, thinking most of
the customer in Seattle, we hate it.
But the reaction once we've got
the interracial stuff is opposite.
It's always the white doctors, white
lawyers. Why Cpa? Yeah. You know,
so well, the disproportionate
amount of interracial porn,
it's sold in the deep south. Oh,
utilize like number one poor market.
It's white dudes, white dudes watching
black guys. Fuck white girls. Yeah.
That couple films him,
it, yeah, those are weird.
But that's something I didn't see
comment. The, the cold market. If folks,
if you're normal and you're listening
to this and you're not all fucked up in
the head like us,
where we can just say caught cold and no
one has to worry whether or not anybody
understands what it means.
Apparently there's a group of dudes
who like watching other guys fuck their
women. Yeah, yeah. And they like,
especially like big black guys.
So what is it called?
The Mandingo clove or something.
There's a lot to bring like seven
men dingoes it's like, like,
it's like just this black crew of
like guys with dicks like you know,
over 12 inches. Whoa. And they just
come and be like, fuck the sure.
12 inches. Just stop and think
about that. It's not just one dude.
There's like many guys with dicks over
12 inches out. That's like a horse race.
I think the vice guys made an
awesome documentary about it shortly.
It's do is a big Dick. It's just
specifically about the cook hold stuff.
It's cold from Mandingo goes Oh.
Like it's a mandate ago.
I didn't,
I didn't even know that was a,
I thought man didn't go was
just the name of a porn star.
But I guess it's a whole movement.
I think. I thought, I thought,
I think the slave owners had a one prize
black guy in each farm and did I think
they call them Mandingo. I think
that's where it started. It real. Yeah.
So you can go to this and get your
wife man didn't go, oh my God,
that's fucking insane thinking about it.
No,
I don't think Mrs Rog and I
appreciate that. Um, yeah,
we should probably wouldn't.
I don't want to know.
That's really what it's about.
I see Joe going to one of those parties
where you are wearing masks, you know,
but I wear a Batman mask,
white porcelain bullshit.
If you make me marijuana mask
and it'd be Batman. But the,
when I did Dave show, we were talking
about David tells a porn show.
Thanks for doing it. But that
was fine. It was a lot of fun.
Yoshi works on that show. But when I
did it and we were looking at John Home,
so like his dick ain't even big by
today's standards. Like it's Kinda crazy.
Like he was the guy who
had the big giant cock.
Now there's so many black guys with
Dick's way bigger than John Holmes. Well,
they weren't allowed. They weren't
allowed in the porn back then. That's why.
Is that what it is? I think
so. Yeah. I'm, I'm matching.
So people had to get
tired of white people,
fucking white women where they're like,
listen,
we've got a million videos of white
girls getting fucked by white guys with
three quarter heart deck. Okay.
Can we bring in some brothers?
And then they're like, okay, we'll just
try this out and see how it works. Boom.
Smash hit big black
dudes with giant Dicks,
fucking white girls and just changes.
And for girls,
like that's like part of their currency,
right?
That they haven't had interracially
like that's like that.
That helps them sell at a
lot of markets, right? Yeah.
Full a full lot of their stars. They,
that their manager would tell them,
don't do it.
Well you could charge more money.
I've talked to extensively
just started in my podcast
with also a carer who just won
2012 what is it podcast called?
All right,
so just like for the same audience out
there that doesn't know what cook hold is.
The name of the podcast is DVD,
a s a n.
It's all the podcasts or a DVD,
a s a.com.
But basically this is a pretty much all
I talked to us about because I was like,
is that true? When you fuck a black
dude then your rate goes down.
And that was actually sort of a
myth. But the shit now, so DVD,
asa stands for double Vatche,
double anal, a sensitive artist.
So
also always gets pissed cause
she's like Dave get it straight.
I didn't do DVD cause if you do DVD a
then it's for Dick's at the same time.
She said I did DV break and
then at another time I did da.
Yeah. So that's two dicks in your
ass at once. And it's like, you know,
it's medically dangerous. I mean she can't
sit for like a week after that. I mean,
it's like really? Yeah. It's like we were,
we were, we just grilled her about this.
It's, and the thing is, why does she
do that? She's a little, you know,
she's five feet two. Yeah.
There's like, there's like the,
Yoshi knows more about porn than I do,
but for what I know,
most of the girls that do this are
usually like ugly and Noni and porn stars.
So for someone like asa who has a huge
name to do it, it's like, it's like, whoa.
Like, and she's tiny, you know? Why
is she doing it? Because it's, well,
check out insatiable to Joe. You'll,
I'll explain it to you. I went, I went,
I went with her to the porn awards.
Insatiable.
I went with her to the porn awards
last year and she won best anal,
best double penetration to two
years in a row. So I was like,
you know, after the thing, you know, it
was a, it's a weird thing to celebrate,
you know? Right. Cause this
is like, you're the best,
but fucky right. You're the,
you got, but fuck the best out of
anyone this year. You're right,
you got penetrated. Oh my
God, I'm so happy for you.
Oh my God, you won the award.
That's amazing. Yeah. But you know, I love
her. So I'm like sitting there and, um,
I think I'm just like,
there's not a huge success
rate for porn stars after porn.
Right.
Like,
it's like you either got a bag of rich
dude or you got to get out before it just
completely destroys your soul
and it's too late. I mean,
yeah, no, you're absolutely right.
And I saw a documentary about it.
[inaudible] porn. Yeah. How was that?
I just saw the first 20 minutes and
it was like super sad and I was like,
oh yeah, I know. And I was like,
you're at the top right now.
You won the fucking,
she was walking out of here like this
with like all the awards. I was like,
you want everything this
year and last year. Right.
And like you fucking dis like for,
I'm trying to tell her to quit.
I'm not trying to totally
equipment like start like,
like if a porn star one performer of
the year, like 10 years ago. Right.
That means she was like really
sexy and like did sexy shit.
Like if win performer of the year now
in 2012 2013 that means you took dicks
like brutally, like you're like slang,
like like a fucking bag of dicks.
Like just giving them
wars and saying good job and so these
girls are working towards these,
you watch these. They don't,
they look like snuff films. Yeah,
they all like getting dragged across
the ground and throwing against the wall
and like, it's like Caveman Shit. Hearst
Hearst. If he checked out insatiable,
which I know is not going to do any more
insatiables as an example in Saint Paul,
she's getting dragged by her hair down
there and just pretty much gagged and it
does. It looks like a snake. It looks
like rape or something horrible.
Why are people into that?
That's what people want.
There's two things people want now,
like shit like that. It's a parody.
It's a thing.
The the, the shemale stuff. It's
like they've already seen everything.
What's the next thing? And it's
funny you said, what is next?
Are you going to have to fucking animals.
You can get your head chopped off
in the next one. Yeah. You know,
what is she saying? I
she, she's one of the,
one of the girls that genuinely loves
porn. Like she loves being, she's like,
and that's why a lot of the fans like her,
cause she's not like,
oh I'm just going to do this until
I get my real estate license.
Like she loves it. So she sent a rough
sex. She loves fucking, she loves it now.
So she's amazing. She is. She is
amazing. I love her. I love her too.
It's a funny thing that people would like,
you know,
the natural instinct is to go, Oh God,
what the fuck are you guys talking about?
She's amazing. She's taking two dicks
in her house. Oh my God. He's amazing.
But the reality is porn is something
that a fucking lot of people watch,
but nobody gives anybody
credit for being good at it.
Oh, I mean, that's the other thing
too is like, he's right about that
because you look,
we've all had bad sexual experiences
where someone wasn't into it.
That girl was like, oh,
you know, and you're like,
and you know you're losing your erection,
right? She's like, what's wrong? I'm like,
what the Fuck's wrong with you?
Like I'm kind of a confrontation that
we have in here. This is nuts. So you,
what you see like on a,
in a scene when a girl is like really
into getting fucked or the reality of it
like gets you excited. Right?
But if someone's sucks at it,
it's not good. Or if all seen bad porn,
I mean, there's a lot of porn out there.
It's not all good.
And usually the hot chicks, you know,
they don't fuck like, Ugh, ugly fat girls,
you know? So when you have a hot chick
that does fuck like, you know, fat,
ugly chick, then it's
like amazing. You know?
And she's amazing because she's done
scenes where gang bangs, bunch of guys,
and I know half of those guys didn't
take a bath. Oh. And she'll smile.
And just do it like professionally
random strangers. That's the other thing.
[inaudible] porn.
So these guys are hoping they doing that.
You don't want that to Mike
to be that close to his mouth.
Cause that's the other thing we figured
out. The podcast is pretty much me,
Yoshi and asa and all this dude does
is eat acid out of hookers and Austin,
she, she eats a lot of acid. Like no,
she said a lot of those guys don't
shower and stuff. So I'm like,
I'm on a show with two people
that he'd asked and all day,
don't get pink eye from this mic are you
probably have a good immune system of
that.
Your immune system is doing
battle all. Yo, she's aids.
I'm glad. I'm glad you
said that. It about me.
Well Yoshi and Brian's
aids in the same room.
What they are is like two competing
beehives and they're fucking,
they're hovering in the middle of the
room trying to work the situation out.
Yeah. Your shorts tells guy
who's aids dominates this room.
You can only get it once.
Right now you get twice.
We had this guy on and uh, I have to
tell people, listen to this podcast,
we have found a molecular biologist
to debate Dr Peter Duesberg.
We had this guy on the podcast and a
lot of people got really angry at me.
He's a professor of biology at the
University of California Berkeley and he's
got this crazy theory about HIV and aids
and he doesn't believe that HIV causes
AIDS.
He believes that the drugs that people
give people for Hiv there what really is
going on with these people's,
they have a compromised immune system
from drug use and you're giving them a
drug that's designed to kill a
disease that they don't even,
it's not even the cause of their illness.
He's saying that caused the illness is
the fact that they're taking all these
drugs and the people
that are in HIV research,
they think he's fucking crazy.
And a lot of people got mad at us for
having them on [inaudible] and it's a
controversial situation because
obviously he's smarter than me. I don't,
I'm not a professor of biology and
he's got tenure and he does like peer
reviewed stuff on, on, on cancer. That's
very well respected like to this day.
But he's got this wacky opinion on,
on an HIV and you know, he insists
that no one wants to debate them.
So we got this guy who was finally willing
to debate them and I'll announce all
of it when everything gets signed away
and we figured out what day they're going
to both fly in.
But we're going to bring him in here and
we're going to have them debate as long
as it takes on the podcast and either,
you know,
either Duesberg is fucking crazy or
do's Burges at genius and we have a real
problem with the way people perceive
this one particular disease.
I don't fucking know.
I'm just hoping that I can figure out
how to navigate through the waters cause
I'm basically going to be like a referee
in a contest that I don't understand.
Right. But, uh, you know, with
aids besides Brian and Yoshi,
well they have the most days, but
uh, yeah, I know a guy was HIV.
I know at least one guy.
The only,
the only time in my life that I've ever
seen anyone with aids and it was like a
lot,
a lot of aids was when I was in Africa.
Like that's like that was part
of Duisburg problem with it.
And he said that what you're seeing
in Africa is not people that have HIV.
It's people that have no,
no nutrition. He's like,
you're seeing compromised
immune systems because they're,
they're starving and they're,
they're in horrible climates.
Where there's a lot of waste around a
lot is you're seeing a lot of different
things. He's like, they're not testing
these people for HIV. He goes, and the,
the amount of people that they have
tested that, that do have HIV in Africa,
he said the number hasn't increased,
but the population has tripled
the population of Africa.
They were saying it's going to be
decimated by AIDS. And he was like, well,
if that's the truth,
why the population increased by
three preparation was like, he said,
it was like, this is all Duesberg,
I'm paraphrasing, but he said,
I believe it was like 500 million and
now it's over a billion. So he was like,
the population tripled. They got 12
inch dicks. They look the fuck. Yeah.
Well the idea is that if aids
was a communicable disease,
like people are describing it,
it would have swept through Africa
and decimated the population.
And he's saying because it didn't, not
even by any stretch of the imagination,
he said it's,
it backs up his idea that it's something
that's brought a bond and in Africa by
poor nutrition in America, by
drug use. I don't know man.
I know gay dudes love to party and
that's something that can't be ignored.
They fucking love to party.
And it could be a combination of them.
Loving to party makes them
more susceptible to certain
diseases and illnesses.
But we all know that I have,
I have a friend who they, they, you know,
they're married and
they're, you know, they're,
they're gay folks and they have
a total normal married life,
but they also have friends who are
gay that they talk about their,
their buddies that they party with.
And these guys are fucking savages.
When you get a direct line into how
gays and these are gay professional men.
I mean one guy,
yeah,
one guy owns a clothing company and
he's really rich. And another guy,
he owned some other business and he,
uh,
he actually pays a straight
guy and had sex with him.
He's like got the straight Russian
guy that, uh, that he paid.
Like the guy was like broke working at
a bar and so for paying him for sex and
he fucks has got a regular button up.
So now it bought this guy car,
puts a guy up in an apartment and just
goes and bangs them and they go out and
they fucking party hard party hard man.
And it might be just be this
guy's buddies, but you know,
when I meet these dudes and they start
telling me stories about the fucking,
the throw downs that they
all have together, wow,
they fucking go out and do crazy drugs.
You know,
they're in this dance culture all the
time and they love to take ecstasy and
they get together and you know,
snorting coke,
that's a part of what they're doing.
That's fun.
And that shit will decimate
your immune system.
Whether or not dues Berg's correct about
all of his assumptions about aids that
outside of,
let's set that aside for a minute and
just look at the fact that there's so many
of these dudes taking those drugs and
that those drugs will fuck you up.
That is a fact.
Whether or not HIV causes AIDS,
the majority of scientists say it does.
So I have to go with them.
I mean the majority support,
the idea that it's this ever
altering and changing disease,
it's very hard to figure out. And then
it decimates immune system if they,
I don't imagine that you could keep
something like that a secret if it wasn't
true. So having him on was, um,
it was a tricky thing
because I can't debate him.
And I had my friend Brian Callin on,
he tried to debate him but he got smushed.
Right. Cause you gotta
have another genius. Yeah.
You're going to have another gene.
Yeah. So we're doing that. So that's,
that's coming up. I'm going to keep hope
alive that there's a cure for you buddy.
No, Yoshi is AIDS isn't curable. It's and
get his own. Yeah, it's its own thing.
It's like a fingerprint. Sorry Bro.
And that's like fucking with my aides,
it'd be like King Kong versus Godzilla.
You could get a film camera in there and
make a cartoon reenactment of what they
say. He would just see aids
doing battle with aids.
The dressed up like gladiators
from a scene of Lord of the rings,
just just ogre aids and on the other
side of troll aids and they have fucking
shields on, on their chest and battering
rams and they're going to war inside.
Yo, she's asked somebody make that cartoon
but you just got to throw that mic out
after this feels though. Yo
should, we will spray it.
I'm going to let you know fill this.
Don't feel sad.
We're going to spray it because I saw a
few of those spittles they flew off your
mouth.
Why you got really particularly excited
about things and that's like Panspermia.
That's how like asteroids hit other
planets and that's how life gets to earth.
I see. So your aids leap
frogging onto that, you know,
very moist sponge microphone cover.
That's like perfect
habitat for super aids.
I just want to make sure they were just
joking. I don't have a cause I'm just,
I can't believe I have to tone down
your fucking professional comedian.
Jesus Christ. Guess what? Brian
doesn't have aids either. Wink, wink.
That's the other shit is like, are
you guys are on iTunes? Yeah. Yeah.
We're on iTunes.
But see like we just started our shit
and we talk about like aids and rape like
every like how the fuck are you
all right? Did you start talking about
poop? Well, there's nothing wrong with it.
You know w what, what, what we're saying,
we didn't say we didn't advocate rape,
we didn't advocate anybody getting dragged
away by their hair or mouth fucked.
We're just like, it's a real,
it's educational podcast.
It's very much an educational part.
I'm surprised where in comedy
and the comedy section.
Well see that's what like we didn't
write in our description like it's DVD a
asa, but we didn't, right. It's double
vaginal, double anal, whatever. And so,
you know, my manager is like, dude,
you could have a porn star on there
and you have this fucking guy.
Like do you want ever to have non
porn star guests? Like real guests on?
Really you'll have normal guests. Well
we have this currency now. Like for me,
I haven't painted in a while and like
my paintings have gone like, you know,
like ridiculously expensive. So I could
paint yes. To bribe them to come on.
And then also said last May and she
said she'll blow anyone who comes on our
show. Really? Yeah. And she was, and
she said, it's like, so like not joking,
like whatever,
can I come? That's, that's, see,
that's what keeps hope alive.
It's good currency to have
you here and things like that.
That is excellent current. So, you know,
people would go on your show anyway,
period. You know, why would they
not want to go on? I don't know.
They don't want their career destroyed.
So silly in this day and age,
people are silly. Gotta they gotta relax.
Just be who the fuck you are. You know?
And especially in a podcast form is the
best place for that because you get a
chance to express yourself for hours.
Definitely.
It's not like if you said
something fucked up and then like,
remember when Hugh grant got blown by
that hooker and got arrested and went on
the tonight show and Jay Atlanta goes,
what the hell were you thinking? Right,
right.
Jay Leno does his famous line that
brought the tonight show back and you know
when they have those shows and
they talk about, you know, the,
the history of the war between the
tonight show and the David Letterman show,
that was the show that turned the tide.
Or Jay Leno looked at Hugh grant and said,
what the hell were you thinking? Right.
Well, when he did that, you know,
and that was like this tiny little
conversation then only took place over a
couple of minutes.
When you love to sit Hugh grant down,
give him a glass of wine and give him
some weed and talked to him for hours and
go like, how many, how many hookers
did you can? You can tell me. Yeah.
I mean you and Elizabeth, whatever
the fuck her name was, he broken up.
She was super hot and she was super
like one of the hottest chicks ever.
And like even with that, do you have to
go out and get this strange new pussy?
He got dirty street. Needed
that nasty. Yeah. He's a rich,
famous man. If he wanted to, he
could. This is before the Internet,
you know what I mean?
He could've gone to get a like la
weekly and gotten a prostitute. Right.
They always had that 30 he wanted,
he wanted it. He wanted to go street
girlfriend, but she's still beautiful.
But my early, early, yes. Hurley,
my reaction was, I don't think she's nasty
and bed. Oh, you just can probably lazy.
Listen. Probably Lazy. Maybe
lazy with Hugh Grant. Oh,
I bet with the right dude gets a hold
of her. She'll fuck the life outta here.
Okay. Yeah. Fair enough. Yeah. It's just,
you've got to impress a girl like that.
You got to fuck the shit out of her.
Right.
That girl's so pretty and she's famous.
You've got to do a lot of work.
So he's probably tired
of doing all that work.
You want to pull over and just get his
dick sucking bitch. Get in the car. So
here's your money. That's what he
wanted. He wanted some crazy moment,
like the exact opposite of
what it is at home or at home.
He probably has to work for it, man. She
probably turns him down all the time.
It's probably argues with them.
She's probably challenges.
That's why I don't understand why
you got married, cause you're,
you're like a free dude. You're
like, I'm going to do comedy,
I'm going to do UFC shit.
I'm gonna have my own podcast.
It's like that part of your
life is so free. And then like,
I've done like everything I can
to like be married, you know,
to not be mad, to not be married and like,
that's why a little bit, well, it's, it's,
it's all about finding the right person.
If you find the right person and you
have starting to having children,
having a child. To me it's way more
of a commitment. The kid first. Okay.
Having a child's Wayne warm got pulling
out. I suck at pulling out. Yeah.
The whole bit about it. The
first one wasn't planned,
the second one was planning.
Oh, okay. But uh, yeah man, I just
preposterous. The idea is ridiculous.
The idea that you're gonna write some
shit down and that someone is going to be
legally entangled with you and then
you're going to have to sit in front of a
bunch of other people when
you want to break up her,
they have to decide how your money
gets distributed. Yeah. It was crazy.
And in your situation, it's a terrible
idea because you've got a lot of money.
That's before I had a lot of money
that I never was into the idea of it.
Of course it's stupid. It's a
stupid idea. My, my wife likes it,
so I did it because we have to make her
up and it makes her happy and I'm not
going anywhere, man. I'm not going to
be that guy. I mean, history, hookers,
none of that shit.
I want to make a robot dirty streets.
So it's not a real close person
or they're getting closer to making that
you were at the Avn awards, right? Yeah,
they had a, they had
fucked up people. Again,
I think the adult video news
awards, they had a lot of, uh,
like kind of real doll technology there.
And then they have one that
like talks to you and still,
it's still kind of just like,
you're fucking a dead person. Oh,
well they had a Japanese, they had a
Japanese robot that was fairly realistic.
It wasn't a sexual robot,
but it was a robot that will like
talk to you and for companionship.
The lips moved fairly. Realistically.
We're going to get to a blade runner day.
It's going to have,
we're getting there.
It's 100% I mean if you look
at the fact that the, the,
the super computers that they had in
the 1960s filled entire rooms and they
didn't have the power
that your iPhone has.
Just think about that and think about
these robots now and what we're going to
have a hundred years from now
or a thousand years from now,
but the blade runner
thing is 100% inevitable.
You're invited to the
wedding with the first robot.
You're going to marry a robot dude.
They'll kill you,
they'll kill you when they
find out that you, you,
you have an explanation data on them.
Can I just,
if you bought super hot robot hookers
and they have this implanted memory or if
their life with you, this perfect
life with you and how deeply, deeply,
deeply in love with you they are,
and then they realize that at line on
year five they die because that's when you
get tired of chicks and you want to bring
in another one and program a new life
into her brain.
This saifai portrait total real.
Here's the thing
thing is like when you go to like a sex
store or a porn convention like that and
you see like the dildos that they have
like this advance a dildo technology,
they teledildonics or whatever.
It's like there's not a human dick
that could do what these dildos do.
They vibrate, they rotate and they
go like this. So I think last year,
right last year was like the first year
I went and I'm walking out and there's
like a hard drive that looks like that
and the guy's like, come over here.
And I'm like, no, he's like,
come over. He's like, he's
like, he's like stickers
finger in that in the computer right
there. And I'm like, no, I don't want to.
And he's like, dude, there was
no one else around. He was like,
just stick your finger in that hard
drive. And I was like, all right.
And I stuck it in and it was wet and it
was warm and it was doing things a human
vagina can never do. It was
like, and I was like, I'm
about to come out of my face.
And I was like,
just the same way girls
who use a lot of builders, they're
pussies become desensitized. I was like,
if I buy this thing right now,
I'll never fucking
leave the house again.
I'll fuck this little computer box.
And if they put it into one of these
android things, I mean there won't be a,
a woman who has a vagina
like tighter than that.
There was a science fiction comic
book that I read when I was a kid.
I'll never forget it was a heavy metal
stuff or it was something along those
lines. It was, um, it was, uh, well,
whatever it was was a black and white one.
I don't remember. It was
a robot that started, um,
the guy had a robot as a, you
know, like a slave or whatever.
But the robot was like very humanlike
and like very muscular and big.
And the robot started fucking his wife
and then he went to stop the robot from
fucking, his wife from the robot broke his
arm. And like, it's really scary thing.
It's rubber. It had this big giant
cock and like it was in the, you know,
the thing that he was
going to continue fighting.
The robot was like laughing as he was
fucking his wife while the guys like
thinking what did I do like
holding his broken arm,
which soft fucked up all
this robot fucks his wife.
But that image like really
stuck into my head. Cause I,
it if we really do develop,
uh,
artificial human being that
thinks it's a human being, right.
And especially if we make
them ridiculously strong or
they're going to fuck your
wife and they're going to break your arm.
If you tried to stop him here, get it.
We're not going to, they're not read
that website. Brian, the robot robot.
Robot robot.
Oh yeah. We're so desensitized. We need
conch holding. We need mouth gagged.
Can Double Anal double vag.
I mean, it's crazy. They already to do
that in Japan. These guys aren't ya? Oh,
Taco.
Like there's crazy fan of a educators
subject like porn or whatever right there
during the ceremonial marriage thing with
the robots and shit like that in Japan.
Oh really? In Japan? Yes, yes. My home
parish. It's weird. I get it. But yeah,
they're doing that. It's, it's really
interesting. I, like I said, I'm happy,
but I wouldn't recommend it. I wouldn't
recommend it on the right one. Yeah.
But it's not, it's not a commander is
I don't like to talk to. Okay. Okay.
The um, um, the odds of finding somebody,
the odds of finding somebody that you get
along with as good as I get along with
her,
they're pretty slim.
I haven't found that many people in my
whole life that I get along with like
that. Right. You just, you get,
it's a compatibility thing cause I'm
not the right dude for a lot of chicks.
Right. You know, and you're not
the right dude for a lot of chicks.
It's like you got to
find the one who's like,
that's what I've been looking for and,
and Eh, well, I'm happy to hear that, man.
That's cool, man. It's good
to be happy. And it's the,
um, the idea of being able
to raise kids. It was always,
I guess a real scary thing
for me when I was younger.
Like it wasn't on when I was
in my twenties. I thought
of it as like a burden.
That's all I thought of it as like, oh
my God, imagine if I had a kid right now,
I'd be fucked.
Right.
I don't even like feeding my cat if
I had a kid like Jesus Christ. Right.
But once you go through the
experience and you'd become an adult,
you kind of have a different perspective
on the idea of a finite lifetime. Right.
And the idea of the,
the concept of being able to raise a
human from the very beginning and like
educate them and expose them to different
things along the way to communicate
with them. How old were you when you had
your first kid? The first biological kid?
I was 40. Uh, see it's totally different.
So guys like you and boarding and give
me hope because I think Bordain had his
first kid or I think it was 50.
I think when he had his
first game or it's, um,
it's easier to understand what's
going on right? When the, when,
if I was 21 if I got my girlfriend
pregnant and I would, I buried her back,
then I might get so overwhelmed by the
responsibility of it all and not being a
Co.
The other thing is that I'm
in a comfortable place in
my life where I don't have
to worry about shit or worry about my
job or I've been working for the UFC for
like 12 years now and then even more
before like 11 year it's been 11 years,
but even more back in the day it's like
another two years from another owner may
have been doing this for so long.
It's not something I worry about losing.
So out of all this, like out of all
the things that you do and you do,
you used to do the fear factor, you
do the UFC, you do your podcast,
you can do standup comedy like out of
all these things like which is your
passion that you,
is it all like I love everything or
I really do love everything, but it's
like all except fear factor. I just,
I loved the money from fear factor.
Right? That was it. Every now and then.
I loved it. You know, every
now and then. It was fun.
It was fun when they were cool people,
you know, look, it could be cool,
but I wouldn't do it
for free. Right, right.
And I would do all the other shit
for free because you love it. Yeah.
It's all the other shit. I don't
think, oh, I'm just doing this for my,
for the money. Right. It's a and
and doing something that you like.
The difference between say the UFC seen
fear factor was sometimes I would enjoy
fear factor. When I worked for
the UFC, I always enjoy it.
I mean I like some people might think is
a boring fight I enjoy because anything
can happen.
It might be boring for a couple seconds
and it dude gets cracked and it becomes
the most exciting shit at me. Right,
right. You know, I'm ready. I enjoy it.
So the differences dif you,
if you're doing something you're
only doing for the money, right?
You're always going to have this,
this feeling like, all right,
just plow through this
and do it for the money.
But when you're doing something that you
love, you'll eliminate that bad feeling.
Well, that's the thing is when
I watched those, I'm like, well,
like when I hear you doing the
announcing for UFC, I'm like,
this guy sounds like he's super, super
pumped right now. Like, you know,
it sounds like you're into it.
So, and like you're like, oh,
when you were like referring
back to fights from like
10 years earlier, I'm like,
is there something in front of you
showing those things you remember?
No, that's not only that. I don't even
do any research. You just love the sport.
Yeah. My, uh, my research can do
some trivia with you. Sure. Yeah.
All right.
So the first time Bj Penn fought George
St Pierre was like in Vegas 10 years ago
or eight?
No, no, it was that long
ago. It was probably 2006 I
would, I would gas, I'm not,
I mean, I, I can't tell
you the exact numbers,
but I can tell you what happened in the
fight. So who won that fight? Uh, well,
George won the fight, but who
really? I thought Bj did more damage.
And all George did was take him down
a couple of times in the later rounds.
But BJ thumb, George and the
eye is a very interesting fight.
He thumb thumb George in the eye in the
first round and the right eye and he had
a cut and that really fucked with them.
And that was the first time George had
faced like real serious adversity inside
the cage.
It's because it wasn't a thumb on purpose.
It's like people have to realize that,
um,
because the fact that thumbs aren't
exposed even with a legitimate punch,
a total, which pj's was
completely legitimate punch,
oftentimes a thumb can go right, right.
Or any of the eyeball. Right. And uh,
you could really fuck up a Guy's
vision from that. And you know,
it was just because Bj had cleaner
striking back then. I mean,
he fucking won the fight.
I think you want to fight too because uh,
I believe he won.
He did more damage and I think ultimately
the Japanese had a better way of
judging fights then. Then the standard
10 point must system that we use,
which is really like a boxing system.
This is unbelievable.
This is fucking crime at Joe's. The real
deal. I mean, you watch how many fights,
the fact that you remember that from the,
well, I've called at least a thousand.
Jesus Christ.
At least
you wanna hear a funny story about
that fight. Yeah, sure. So I just,
I was in the Congo.
How many stories begin with that?
I was there, I was there for vice and
I, and I just came back to La and, um,
I have a bit of a gambling
problem and the way my gambling,
uh, career, I guess is
set up is, um, basically,
yeah, 2006 or around that time, like six,
seven years ago when I was going there,
I was going there every week and
winning about a thousand dollars.
And then I would stop. That's, I could,
I could for sure go to Vegas and when,
you know, between 800 and a thousand
dollars, you know, and that,
that was what I was doing for money.
And then I would be painting
on the side or whatever.
And I would do that every week.
So I came back from Africa and
I was going to go on, you know,
I was going to fly to go or
drive to go see my parents.
I hadn't seen them in a few months.
And um,
Bj was being sponsored by their clothing
company. Ruca do you know RVC sure. Yeah,
I know those guys. So pat the owner is
one of my best friends and he goes, Dave,
you've got to take a BJ's. The fight was
the next day with George Saint Pierre.
And he said, uh, something with the
logo was not big enough or something.
So he still had the pants. He's like,
these pants need to get to, to, to, uh,
to Bj in Vegas. And I said, all right,
so sense of why, why do I got to go?
He's like, cause you fucking Love
Vegas. And I'm like, dude, I,
I'm still wearing the same clothes that
I was wearing in Congo for like two
months. Like I need to go shower, I
need to go see my parents. He's like,
he's like Dave.
And then he passes me $40,000,
which was the most amount of cash I'd
ever seen in my life. And he goes,
you need to go put this on Bj to
win. And I, Whoa, dude. He's like,
you love to gamble. I trust you. He
goes, go give Bj his pants and you know,
go give Bj's pants and go put this
money on Bj Darwin. And I was like,
are you sure dude? And
he's like, I was like,
so he gives me, um, he
gives me a clean shirt.
It was just like a Bj Penn security
shirt. You know what I said, Bj Penn and,
and security on the back.
So I take the red eye into Vegas and
sitting next to me in a safe way.
Plastic bag is Bj Penn's pants
and in my pocket is $40,000.
And he goes, when you get to Vegas,
go to go up to the penthouse Bj,
it was at Mandalay Bay, I think.
He goes, go, go to Mandalay bay.
And at this point I knew Bj. I wasn't
as pretty good friends with them now,
but I didn't know him that well back then.
So I get there and I go upstairs to
his room and he travels with his whole
family. Then they, you know,
they're usually like loud and fun and
I get up to the room and uh, I have,
I have his pants ago. Pat told me to bring
you your parents and he's like, okay,
thanks. And his brother,
Reagan's like, it's just,
it was like a weird vibe in the room.
And I was like,
what the fuck is going on dude?
He's like, come over here.
He's like the guy in the next room
over brought home a 20 year old,
21 year old hooker.
Fucked her and strangled her and then
just dropped her in the hallway and until
her and killed her,
she's dead.
And because she was dead in the
hallway right in front of Bj's room,
they took beach even though
they knew he didn't do it.
Like they took him in for questioning.
Yeah.
So I'm like freaking out and
he's like, dude, Bj's at the,
been at the police station all
day answering questions and he's,
he has his fight tomorrow night. So
I'm like, whoa. So I run downstairs.
I called Pat Pat. This was the day
of the wins or the day of the fight?
The day before. The day
before, day before the wedding.
So he wasn't cutting any wait for
that day right before the fight.
The day right before the fight.
So Day of the wedding. Yeah. So I,
I don't know exactly cause I
just got there at midnight.
So I go downstairs, I go,
Pat, are you sure you want
me to put this money on him?
Because he just came back from
the police station. He might not,
he might have a little fuck
dude. BJ's a champ. He doesn't,
he's going to fucking smoke this guy.
And for a guy who's been
the Vegas like every week,
I go there every week for like the last
20 years, I had never been to Vegas.
It felt like this before. More Hawaiians
that had never left Hawaiian. We're it,
you know, this was like, they weren't
even like the main fight, right?
But like George Saint Pierre
is the hero of Canada,
so there was all these fucking
Canadians in, in Vegas.
And then there was all these Hawaiians
in Vegas and it was just like a fuck fuck
Canada and like fucking Hawaii.
Like it was like I was playing cards and
people would see my Bj pincher and they
go, fuck Bj Penn, Fuck Hawaii. And then
there are all these people will be like,
it was like electric. Like it was like
crazy. And I was like, wow, pat, you want,
are you sure rude? And then this
is where I found out that, uh,
a sports book is not
actually part of the casino.
It's a separate entity
that's like rinse out.
So I went and I said 40 grand on Bj Penn
when, after I talked to Pat, I was like,
Hey, are you sure you want me
to put this money? He's like,
Bj is going to kill this guy.
It doesn't matter. He's, he's,
he's got the heart of a champion.
And I was like, all right.
And I go in there and the odds,
if you don't remember,
everyone already thought Bj was going to
win. So if I put 40 grand on Bj to win,
I would only got back like 30 grand
I think. And if I put 40 on St Pier,
I would've got back like 70,000 I think.
So the odds are way in Bj Penn's favor
so they wouldn't even take a bet that
big. So I was like, Oh shit.
So he's like, and they were,
all the sports works were
closing so they were like,
you have to do it the next day. So
I was like, all right, I'm going to,
I'll just go to a strip club I guess.
So I go to a strip club and as soon
as I walk in or get out of the car,
a security guard sees me and
he goes right this way sir.
And then he takes me to like this
giant private room and I'm like,
still smell like shit from Africa.
And I'm like,
they just bring over the hottest
strippers. And then I'm like,
what the fuck's going on? And I realized
I'm wearing a Bj Penn security shirt.
So they think Bj's coming. They're like,
they're like, when's Bj gonna come here?
And all the security guards
are like sucking my dick,
just like Bj's is the best.
He's going to win the fight tomorrow. And
I was like, I was like, oh. So I'm like,
I'm going to take advantage
of the situation. I'm like,
I'm like sitting there with my friend
Harry. We were like getting lap dances,
all this shit. And then I was like, fuck,
they're going to at some point
expect media to come here.
So I sneak out the side and then,
uh,
I don't think I slept that night. And then
the first, you know, I was, I was, I was,
it was one of those nights where I stay
at the Strip club till like the sun
comes up and then the next day I start
putting the money down on Bj to win.
But it was like seven grand at like the,
you know,
the Venetian and then like eight grand
over here and had to split it up a little
bit. So I, I,
I was like running around and I couldn't
get the money spread out so I was only
able to bet like 32 grand and I
still had eight grand in cash on me.
And then the fight starts and like you
said, like it was just like you said,
like everyone, the place is going
nuts. Like it's going fucking insane.
Like everyone's like fuck, like getting
off, Fuck Hawaii. And it's like,
and then the fight happens. I'm like, Oh
fuck St Pier, it looks bloody first round.
I'm like, this fights done like Bj, Bj
one and then saint peers, a smart fighter.
So he liked deflected a lot or whatever.
And then when decision time came around,
they gave it to St pier by one point
decision and the place goes whoa.
And they started like screaming like
I couldn't believe it. Like I'm like,
oh my God, cause I had my own money
on the fight too. He walks offstage,
his brothers like get them
drunk right away. And then,
I don't know if you go out at
all after the fights or whatever,
but I've never seen Vegas this
violent before in my life.
Like there was like street
brawls inside casinos.
There was Canadians beating up Hawaiians,
Hawaiians beating up. Like, it was crazy.
I knew Hawaiian guy that put his house
up for the whole thing. And yeah,
I mean, it was insane. People
were going crazy. I've never,
in all the years I've been in Vegas,
I've never seen a situation like this
where people had his house on Bj. Yeah.
I mean it was fucking crazy. So what
do you win when you bet your house?
I don't know.
I think in another house,
I think you've just put the value of
it up. I don't know. I don't know.
The details are there. So he lost his
house. Yeah. So he lost his house and,
and yeah. You saw the fight. I mean,
I was looking at that guy's an idiot move.
I mean,
especially when you know that the
judging and MMA judging and then my man,
so sketchy. Yeah. I mean it was,
it was fucking crazy. So then, um,
just as a side thing,
the girl that I was with were seven
years then we had just broken up,
happened to be in Vegas.
So I was having dinner with her after
and I was telling her what's happening.
I was like, dude, I just lost $32,000
off my friends money on this thing.
And she was like, oh. And I was
calling him and I was saying, Hey pat,
I still have eight grand of your money.
Do you want me to gamble with it?
And when you're 32 grand
back and he's like,
get your fucking ass back over here.
Like he was so pissed off and so I was
just having dinner with her and then he
calls me back and he goes,
you know what I was,
I was planning on winning the money or
losing it. So go for it. And I was like,
you want, I can do this. And remember
I've only won a thousand dollars.
That was like the most
money I've ever won.
I never even had like 8,000 or
40,000. So I was like, shit,
I'm going to walk into that high limit
room for the first time in my life. So,
but I'm talking with her and you know,
like right after a long break,
you've been together with someone
for a long time and you break up.
There's like that maybe we're still going
to get together. So like I'm like, fuck,
I'm going to go gamble right now.
And then in this situation, uh,
the fuck was that guy, the rush
hour guy, Chris, Chris Tucker.
So Chris Tucker and like, you know, a
posse of like 40 people like walk in.
Then they start hitting on her right
away, right when I got up. So I was like,
fuck, I got to go win this money. But like
Chris Tucker, it looks like he's gonna.
I was like sorta stuck. I was like, fuck,
this mother fucker is hitting on my ex
girlfriend. And I was like, all right,
I'm just going to run and do it.
So I walked into the Venetian high limit
room for the first time and then eight
grand in like thousand dollars
chips. It's like, you know,
it's like a little stack.
And I split it up and I started
playing like my system, the way I play,
and I won about 36 grand
within like 15 minutes. Whoa.
And that fucked me up.
It's like smoking weed your whole
life and then doing cocaine, you know?
So then I called him, I was
like, Hey pat, I, I'm up to 36.
You want me to win the last?
He said,
get your fucking ass back to Costa
Mesa right now. I was like, all right.
All right. All right. I was like, I
really think I could win the whole 40.
He's like, stop, stop right now. So I
stopped. And then, uh, yeah, I mean,
I sort of blame basically Bj for my
gambling problem because after that,
after that moment, I could never go to
Vegas again and just win a thousand.
I had to like win at least
20 grand because of the
rush. You can't go backwards,
you know? Like, I'm like, I just
want 36 grand with this guy's money.
Why can't I win it with
my own money? Right. So,
and I didn't have that kind of money
to gamble with, so I, you know,
I like took a loan out to do it.
Like it was, he took a loan out.
I was like started, I was very confident
that I could do it, you know, so. Wow.
Yeah. And how did that work out? I made a
small fortune doing that. I can't, yeah,
I can't, I can't play it. Most of
the casinos in Vegas, I don't know.
What do you play?
I play every table game play poker.
I don't really play so much.
I played for fun and like now like
sometimes they invite me to like celebrity
poker things. I beat actually all the UFC
guys. That'd be truck Ladell I beat uh,
uh, um, fuck. I can't think of the
guy's name right now. What is it about,
why are you so good at this?
Why are you still get a card games?
I think to answer your question,
I think it's because I'm really good at
also pulling out, you know, like, no,
I'm not even joking.
I'm really awesome at it.
Like people were like the
amount of funding you do,
the fact that you haven't got a girl
pregnant right now. Right. I'm like,
because I'm extremely
disciplined, you know? And um,
I knew that I would like gambling sex,
like drink and anything that is enjoyable
is, becomes an addiction, right?
Because
if you're an addict,
you want to keep doing it and you can't
stop and then you're like in like an AA
thing going,
I don't know.
I just went into the bar to have one
drink and the next thing you know,
and that's everyone in poker,
that's everyone's biggest
story. Right. Right there.
Like I was up and then like that's why
Vegas is there because no one ever saw
the type of person that I actually
can stop. I know that I can't stop.
So I hire someone to come with me to
physically make me stop real. Yeah.
And I've been doing that since I was 15.
You've hired someone to come
gamble with you since I have no,
not from 15 to 23.
I consistently lost every
paycheck that you know,
and I would be going back from
Vegas with that. I don't understand.
Like I worked at Toysrus for two months
and made a couple hundred dollars and I
was like, I went to Vegas and I doubled
it, but now I'm leaving with nothing.
Like it was that like I had it right,
but why didn't I leave with it?
Nobody leaves with it and it
was just baffling. I was like,
you can come to Vegas and when people win
money here but nobody ever leaves with
it. What is that? What the fuck is that?
And it's like the same thing
as an alcoholic who like
I had a nice buzz going,
why did I have to take it to the point
where like blacked out and was puking?
It's like, cause you
can't stop. So I was like,
if I can pinpoint if I can know about
myself and be honest with myself that I
definitely cannot stop. Why don't I just
hire someone to stop me? I tell them,
look, when I get to this number
stopped me and if I keep going,
grab me by my throat,
picked me up.
And so I developed this whole
system of like, you know,
pulling out and it's uh,
it worked for a long time and it actually,
it helped like in every aspect of my life.
Like,
so do you have this guy with
you everywhere you go? Well,
I did for a long time. You know, he's
like, hold on, let me check your balls.
You're not ready to come yet. Now.
He was awesome. He's a Harry Kim.
He was like my partner. We hitchhiked
around the whole world together.
We did a show on vice where we
hitchhiked from like La to Miami,
Tijuana to Alaska, Beijing,
the Hong Kong. Holy Shit.
So I filmed a show doing it.
We filmed the show doing it and it's
called thumbs up and yeah. I mean,
what year did you do this?
This was years ago.
We probably did the first one
seven years ago. Wow. Yeah.
So yeah, to answer your question, yeah, I
did bring him everywhere with me and, uh,
doing that allowed the both of us to
like actually never grow up, you know,
cause we're like, hey, let's keep fucking,
let's keep the party going. And was like,
okay, let's just go to Vegas and when 20
grand and we would do it. And you know,
that's, that's around the
time we met you. Right.
And Jill Harris Great. He's
like catty, wouldn't you say
like, Hey, let me help you.
Right. And I'll be watching him gamble
and I don't have a stomach for it.
Like there's Times David Lucy and
thousand 5,000, 10,000. Like I,
I just had to walk away by
Harry sell discipline and um,
he gives them good advice
and they worked as a team.
So I leave a couple of hours later,
they'll come back,
they're just pull hundreds of,
you know, just bills on the bed.
How does that work? They'd tell you can't
come and play in the casino anymore.
It's not like a,
your band.
But there they definitely let you know
you're not welcome anymore. Like they,
they make all kinds of things
uncomfortable for you to cow,
like a casino that is welcoming to me.
Like,
and I'm not like some weird like
math genius or anything. My,
my method like I could explain to you
right now how to pull out. Right. Okay.
Like you fuck a girl and when it feels
good you just pull out like way before
you're going to come, you know. So I
could sit here and like the shit with me,
gambling is a super simple and I actually
haven't gambled in the long time cause
I don't need to anymore.
But basically, um,
it's, I could explain it to
you, but to actually do it,
it's like almost impossible. And I know
that too. That's why I have Harry with me.
And it's like if you go to Vegas
right now because of card counting,
because of all these like
math nerds and shit blackjack,
the most Max maximum bet you could
ever bet on black jacket is 25,000.
So that's that. That's the end. Yeah.
That's the restrict you from going
crazy from playing progressive,
you know, like basically progressive
is if you bet and you lose,
you just double it each time so you
can just keep doubling forever. Right.
If have the bank roll and
you'll never lose, right, right.
I bet $10 I lose it then. And then
once you get it back, you're out. Ben,
you start over at $10 a year. Right. You
know, and they, they get, they have a,
they have a cap at 25 you're always ahead.
But I got to a point,
I mean Vegas, the Vegas stories
I got, I could, you know,
there are just like unreal.
Like I got to a point where
they got rid of that for me.
They would let me bet whatever I want.
I was betting like a quarter million,
a hand on blackjack.
So
Jesus fucking Christ.
What does that feel like in your hands
and your feet and your, your spinal cord.
The shemale of gambling.
It's like,
it's like you've done everything,
you've done everything and nothing
works anymore. Like, you know, you get,
you're like,
you've done everything,
you've done anal and you've gotten the
blow job, you know, asked to mouth.
You don't ask them about
if you've got the aids,
you've got everything you need to
play it a shit and now you're like,
I have like I'm going to have to eat shit.
And it's been, and it was progressive.
It was like,
you know,
every time I went to Vegas I would win
$1,000 then every time I went to Vegas I
won 20 grand and then saw your brain goes,
well why couldn't you do it with
the same style but with more money?
And as long as the casinos kept
letting me raise the Max bet,
I could keep pushing it harder and harder.
And then who you are right now
are creating gambling addicts.
They're listening to this. Like
this guy is smart. I'm smart too.
I'm going to go out and make a
living gambling. Fuck, walk in here.
You have to risk everything. You have
to risk everything. Like you're ready.
Like you might have to risk
like everything you worked
for like your whole life.
So that you can, when you're,
you don't, you can't pussy out.
Like if you're going to go for it,
then you have to pull the trigger.
So how do you change the odds? The odds
are that the casino wins 51% of the time.
Right? More plus. Plus is it? Plus?
What is it? You're not going to,
you're not going to take down Vegas.
You don't.
You're going to just stick the tip in
and get a little bit and then it's like
bail and then do, it's like, it's
like Vegas is Goliath and your list,
tiny little speck and you're just
taking little nicks out of it.
You're not trying to take the house down.
How do you keep doing it though?
How do you keep putting
it on the positive side?
I still don't understand how you overcome
the 51% is the 51% of mathematical
thing because they're dealing with
what is the 51 whatever the number is.
If people are in correcting, it's the how,
three, something like that. It's always,
but it's pretty much 50 50 right.
Baccarat is I think the best odds of
any game because which ones that which
ones?
I know buck rod is like,
you're trying to get to natural
nine a natural night. It's,
it's Baccarat is like one
of the stupidest games ever.
It's what James Wall in place.
It's the mother fucker. It's, it's,
it's the game where when you walk past,
it's always Chinese people writing numbers
down and screaming and tearing up the
cards. Like, but basically it
looks the most complicated,
but it's like the same thing
as them flipping a coin.
Like there's nothing you can do,
you can't hit, you can't stay.
Whatever's gonna happen is gonna happen.
You could bet house or you can bet banker.
So it's the closest to like a 50 50
kind of bet you can. You can bet.
And so basically, like I
said, you bet progressive.
Every time you lose you just double it.
And the second you win it,
you just go upstairs,
lock it up.
And you just do that a couple times and
then you leave and you don't want every
time Jesus Christ, you don't sit there
and you go, oh, I'm trying to like,
and you leave when the
feeling is the best, like,
like breaking it down a sex again
is the best feeling after you come.
Cause after you come you
just want to go to sleep.
The best feeling is like when
you're about to come, you're like,
you feel it coming. You know? I guess
coming actually is, I don't know.
Cummings over
depends on if someone's rubbing
your balls are not, is overrated.
I think so. Well it's because you're
pulling out all the time. Yeah.
That's my shit. Loads and chicks. It's
a hundred times better. It is like,
that's why everybody,
we remember when you were young,
you were psyched when your girlfriend
was on the pill. You're like, oh yeah,
no condos bomb blast inside of our,
it's the greatest feeling of all times.
I'm so much better than pulling out.
Yeah, that's, that's true. It's true.
I'm so psyched that you fucking have
this like unbelievable recall with these
fights.
Dj One. That fucking fight man. Yeah,
that I, well it was very close though.
You know the real problem is in judging,
there's a, there's an issue in judging.
There's an also an issue in the way
they're scoring fights at 10 10 point must
system. It's like what's a ten eight
round? What's a ten seven round? I mean,
does it, is it about damage is about
knockdowns is about ground control.
I mean I just mentioned it
to Canada. That's why I was
like, hi, Canada's awesome.
Hey, how could you say that? We're both
band from Canada. It's fucking amazing.
It's so fun. Me and Yoshi both can't go to
Canada or Japan. Well, you're both. Fuck.
I'll tell you what. Canada is this
shit. I'm going to Montreal and mark.
What are you talking to? Boot. I
love it. They talked a little odd,
but they're the nicest people on earth,
that's for sure. I love it up there, man.
I can't, I'm getting booked. I think
I'm doing Vancouver in March, booboo,
so hang on, hang [inaudible].
Last night at a show. Yeah.
Canadians. The shit man. If I left Camp
America, I would move to Canada for sure.
I would really move to Vancouver if
I was not going to live in America.
I need to live in Hawaii or Vancouver.
I go to Hawaii. Yeah, because Hawaii,
Hawaii's not really America.
American might own that shit little shit.
That's a why and I mean it's just
under the umbrella of protection.
That is not America.
That's Hawaii.
That's why a lot of white people go over
there and have real problems cause they
started tried to treat it like it's
the rest of America. Right, right.
Instead of treating it like you're
moving to a foreign, I don't know.
That's its own nation, man. They've
got their own shit going on over there.
It should be. It should be. You know,
it should be like we have like
cousin nations, like Puerto Rico.
Puerto Rico is like, are you, are you
planning a, an exodus out of here?
I tried to while ago. Man, where were
you going to go? I moved to Colorado.
I got a house.
I leased it instead of buying it just
because the check is this manager's like
flesh. He says, please just check it out
for a little bit. Save your money kid.
Right. Saving for a rainy
day. You know, I'm like,
let's buy a house in the mountains.
So it was a on the top of a mountain and
my dog got eaten by Mountain Lion. Whoa.
Yeah. That'd became a bit in my
act. And if you play in the podcast,
drinking game drink, shit, it became a
bit in my act, but it really, it was true.
I really did see a mountain
lion in my yard. I was on a,
it was a huge piece of land right on
the top of the mountain above boulder.
You're going to solve a lot of problems
with me right now. This when fault.
It was, um, well my daughter,
my second daughter was conceived up there,
so it was about three years ago
because I have that fantasy of like,
fuck la, fuck the traffic. Fuck
this. I just got to get away.
But then I realized I fucking hate nature.
I have,
I don't know how he is a thing. I
don't know. To kill a mountain lion,
the nature is not the issue.
The issue is you have to
understand where you're at.
You have to understand your environment
and you have to have the resources to
make your environment compatible to you.
You have those resources.
You're not like a regular person living
in the mountain riding a donkey to work.
Right? Okay. So you've got some
cash. You could hire someone,
apply your fucking driveway,
you could hire someone to put
motion detector lights on.
So if there's mountain lions
creeping in your backyard,
the lights hit him and they
run away. Right? You could,
you could protect yourself.
So then what happened with you? Why
did you, my wife got pregnant. And uh,
when you're up in the mountains,
it's an extremely high out too.
We were at 8,600 feet above sea level
and it's hard walking up a flight of
stairs, right? And when you get
pregnant, it's actually dangerous.
It's dangerous to, the fetus is
not good. So you're like, fuck,
I got to get it out of there.
And yeah,
and she's not so good at driving in snow
or would you go back now? Fuck yeah.
Fuck yeah. I would live in
maybe the city of boulder a lot.
I think the city of Boulder's a better
mood or was it right in the foothills?
Are you from originally?
No,
I was born in New Jersey and I grew up
most of my life in Boston. Okay, so,
so what is it you're just done with
la? No, it's just that I'm, I love La.
There's a lot of la that I love.
Here's what I love about La.
I think the coolest fucking human beings
I've ever met in my life live here.
Right. You know, I mean, I
just met you today, but I
think it's pretty bad ass. Yo.
She's cool as fuck.
These two guys are okay.
All my friends live here
except for Stan hope.
Like all my favorite comedians live here.
Joey D as an Ra should fear and
Duncan Trussell and Greg, Eddie Bravo.
It's like I know so many people in La
that I love that this is where my family
is. It's not just where my family
of people that I live with, it's my,
my family of humans that I love.
They're all in la. However,
this is a stupid place to stay.
And if we can get all the people that
I love and everybody was like, listen,
I love you. You love me. Let's get
the fuck out of here. Right, right.
Why don't we have to play to be in a
place in this 20 million people on the
fucking highway and there's
nothing cool to look at.
The beautiful thing about Colorado
to me was the natural beauty.
And that to me is like,
it gives me a feeling that like your
artwork is awesome. I love your artwork.
Beautiful. You're very talented,
you're very expressive and you know,
just you talking to you as a human being.
I love,
I love when I meet someone
and they're intelligent.
And you could see that intelligence
expressed in a form of art.
And that's why people love art. You
know, people love art because like,
I can't play music. I don't, I don't,
I don't know anything about how
to play any instrument at all.
So I love music because it's, to
me, it's like something I can't do.
So I watched it. I'm like,
wow, that's amazing. And it's
so inspirational, exciting,
and I can take it in and almost
has as an infant tile level,
what does that say about Yoshi?
That he doesn't, he's a master.
He doesn't listen to music.
Neither does Doug. Stan hope. And I love
him to death. I love the weird thing,
whatever. It's life. But my point
was, but well, let me just finish,
go full circle with this,
is that in Colorado,
the natural beauty is so astounding that
everywhere you look you're like, ah,
oh. Like there was this place
that we used to drive. Um,
we would go up to this area
called Nederland and you
drive through the mountains
to get there. And as you're
driving through the mountains,
like you can't even believe
you're allowed to be here.
You're just seeing the snow covered
peaks in these giant dropoffs and fucking
trees everywhere.
And it's just majestic.
And the clouds float overhead and you
realize like this is God's country, right?
Like you,
you are witnessing the,
the impact of your
environment is substantial.
It's the idea that we should only measure
things that you could fuck a put on a
scale.
That's what you're not counting in is
the visual benefit you get from seeing
art. That's why people buy art or they
love art. They love having it there.
There's also art in nature and that's,
that's reality.
If you live in a place that's
boring as fuck to look at, right?
It's not inspirational. But when
you're in Colorado and you're driving,
you're driving up Sunshine Canyon.
He loves Colorado's driving around.
He's fucking trees and mountains that
the same thing can be said about northern
California,
right?
If you go like to Humboldt drive
around Humboldt drive around the,
where the sequoia national forest is,
they have these giant redwood trees
and he was like, God damn like Tahoe,
go to Tahoe,
see the fucking mountains,
look at all those trees and the
look at the giant lake and just say,
you take it in
Colorado in every spot you just named.
I love it too. Like it's I, yeah,
it's fucking breathtaking. It's
upset. It's just two weeks,
two whites, you know, God damn.
There's a lot of white people.
If you had a dance contest in Colorado,
they would call it off.
It's just the middle of the night.
They would say, no one wins. It's this.
It's this completely like,
it just makes me, I guess, a
little bit uncomfortable, you know?
I could totally understand that.
That's why I got to Hawaii.
It's got the natural beauty and it's
diverse enough where that's a good point,
you know, and the, yeah,
that's a good point. I could see that.
The only problem with Hawaii's, his land,
it's locked. It's just like it's a
small piece of land. There's not a lot,
dude. The volcanoes are an issue only
on the big island. Really. I mean,
it could look a volcano.
The real volcano issue was Yellowstone,
and if that mother fucker goes,
you're better off being on Hawaii than
you are in California. Right. Yellowstone.
And it was essentially the pregnancy
that got you out of Colorado. Yes.
If she wasn't, then you probably stay,
I don't know, man. The loser. No,
I see.
I grew up in Boston,
my formative years from
13 to 24. Right. And I,
I had a newspaper route when I was a kid
when I had a car. Right. And it was, uh,
I was fighting in taekwondo tournament's
all I did was delivering newspapers in
the morning and then in the afternoon
and then compete. So I drove every day.
Right. So I drove in a lot of snow.
Right. So for me, driving in snow,
it's just second nature.
I knew how to handle that shit.
I knew what it's like to get stuck.
I got stuck every year, you know,
it didn't freak me out. I've walked miles
home. Car was in the ditch, you know,
because it's spun out on the highway.
I've done it, I did all that shit. Right.
And when you grow up in a
place like Massachusetts, you,
you experienced that fucking ruthless
weather and you get just, it,
just accept it so that,
that 10 plus years of my life is in my
brain and I just pull that cartridge out
and shove it in there.
But my wife is from Texas and when she's
never driven in snow before and all of
a sudden she's like,
she doesn't know what the fuck to do when
the ass end goes. Right, right, right. No,
I know.
You got to spin into that shit.
You gotta you gotta I know how to
balance a car when it starts to slide.
And even then you've got to accept the
fact that you can't deal with black eyes.
He hit black ice. You're going to crash.
Right. I have all these things in my head,
but to a person who's never
grown up in cold weather,
that's a terrifying variable that
you've just added to the equation.
Well,
black freeze to death.
The black guys get really
angry when you try to hit them.
That black hat and a
black guy, oh, black ice,
black ice [inaudible]
you've never driven on a uh,
like a a road and it rained
and it like black guy.
I was like,
just try to hit black guys in Colorado.
Have you ever driven on black ice? No.
It's the most terrifying shit ever.
You're driving and then all of a sudden
the road goes out from under you and you
start spinning.
Have you ever driven on like a northern
road in the winter? No, fucking day.
That's the thing,
man.
That's why I was saying I have this
like fantasy of like fucking la and then
these visions of like this
post apocalyptic like riots
and fires and I'm like
just get out and then I realize I don't
know shit about wilderness and nature
and driving learn, learn, all that. That
shit you could learn all that shit. The,
the, the driving in the snow is difficult,
but people have done,
they've moved from cow.
A lot of people move from California to
boulder right after the 94 earthquake.
93 earthquakes. Yeah, that's about
right. Whatever it was that big earth,
the Northridge earthquake,
when your instinct is to go colder,
mountainous and I think mine would
be to go South America. I, you know,
growing up in Boston does I,
there's something that I appreciate
about cold weather because it gives you a
certain respect for the possibilities that
mother nature can throw at you. Right.
On a regular basis and it
sounds ridiculous to one and
put yourself through that.
All right.
And when I was young I s I was mostly
was a person who sought comfort,
so I wanted to get out of the snow
and get out of the all that as much as
possible and find a nice place
so I could take a nap or it.
As I've got older I realized that that
is one that's one of the things that sort
of steals you as a human being is
overcoming adversity and dealing with
difficult situations. I think it's,
it's good to know that winter's coming.
Do you like traveling overseas? Yeah, I
don't mind it. I don't like plane flights.
I love, I love going to different
cultures or plane flights are just such a
motherfucker,
but I love being in any new cultures.
So it's so interesting to me that
people can develop, you know,
on the same planet in different areas
geographically and have completely
different sets of values and ideals.
And I love comparing their,
their takes on family and politics.
It's fascinating to me.
Endlessly endlessly fascinating to me
that we can all exist in 2013 but be very,
very,
very different.
That's why ensign on the
podcast last night was talking
a lot about Japan, right?
We were talking about Japanese culture
and why he loves it so much and the
Japanese people and how,
how well they responded to the Fukushima
incident and all those people orderly
in line waiting for, you know,
for aid. You know, it's crazy.
Japanese are the only ones in all
of Asia that will wait in line.
So disappointed everyone else's
because there's a social
contract with everyone, you know?
And I'm not saying that our culture
is socks and their cultures better.
I'm not saying that at all.
I mean,
and people get real nationalistic and
really a lot of people had gotten upset
with me about a lot of the things that
I've said about America on the podcast.
And they say a lot of silly shit.
I'm not saying,
I'm not saying I'm not, I don't believe
I believe in, I believe in human.
I believe in the concepts of of nations.
And in that sense,
I love the concept of America more than
any nation in the world other than the
military industrial complex.
Actually,
I don't know,
remember that when the earthquake was 93
[inaudible] 94 but people surprise me,
they were helping each other out
planned. I mean, they were amazing.
The people that who usually
don't like each other,
they sit that shit aside and
they were helping each other.
I was listening to a lecture on this
and there's something funny about the
complexities of
human behavior and emotions and
it's like a, it's like, you know,
when people are like, hey, how
come is it possible? Are we not?
Can we not be happy and sad at the
same time? Right. Yeah. So the,
the earthquake happened, right? Yeah. And
it just shook the shit out of my house.
Like my cousin almost got flattened
by like this giant dresser. And, um,
I lived on a street with
a lot of old people,
so me and my brother went and we went
around the block helping all these old
people turn off their
gas line so that there,
there was an old couple trying to find
their gas line with, with a lighter on it.
And so we went around the whole block and
we with the flashlight and then we made
sure everyone had their gas
line off so that you know,
the neighborhood wouldn't explode. And
then after that, then we wouldn't looting.
I'm on your fucking,
that's insurance is for,
I'm on your team.
You did the right thing for humanity and
you took advantage of a disenfranchised
situation you found yourself in because
of the inequities of the situation that
the different system, this is
what we operate under, right?
And they're going to make lock
down. I didn't know that. Yeah.
We want to make sure everyone's
all right neighborhoods cool.
And then go get some fucking
dean equities of the situation.
You find yourself in a forced
you to drastic actions.
There's nothing wrong with what you did.
You did the right thing humanly.
He humanitarian wise with your
friends. Yeah. Good for you man.
I was listening to a lecture on this
very subject today on the way over here.
It just coincidentally
completely coincidentally and
the guy was saying that the
um,
one of the issues that we have with
modern culture and the attitude of modern
society,
when you watch like the Kardashians show
or you watch like nonsensical bullshit
on TV or worse yourself. Yeah. And
the, the sort of culture of gossip.
The reason for that is because we are
in a situation where we have massive
abundance of resources where everyone can
get gas on every corner and you can go
to a store of choice, even if you're
poor, you can't afford fatty foods. Right?
So that, that, that, that,
that lack of need for character and lack
of need for any sort of real drastic
effort to overcome your environment.
Like everybody else all over the world
allows us to get really fucking conti and
really stupid and soft and lazy because
we only have to do as much work as we,
you know,
we need to survival and survival is easy.
Then your brain is left to fucking dwell
on stupid shit like the Kardashians or
like, you know, who wore
this dress better or why,
why is this guy have a car like that?
And I got this piece of Shit,
you know, I call it the toilet paper
situation. So going back to the Congo,
when I was in the Congo, I realized a lot
of places they don't have toilet paper.
Like even in like just public restroom and
stuff. And for those who don't know, I,
I need to shit a lot.
Yeah.
Like I need to shit all the time.
And especially in a country like
that where shit is definitely coming.
Aye.
Well I went to their version of a
supermarket, which was just sparse.
They had nothing. And I was like,
I need that Congo Brazzaville,
the city part before I went into
the jungle. So I went in and,
and you go to the section and you go,
where's the toilet paper?
And there's a toilet paper, it's just
there. And then you're like, okay,
it's just a thing of toilet
paper when you buy it.
And then reflecting later on when I'm
here and I go to Ralph's and I'm standing
in the aisle of the toilet paper,
there's like 50 different brands
is to apply for, apply quilted,
sent it unscented. And you're
just sitting there and I'm like,
which one should I get? Like, which one
will be feel the best on my asshole,
you know?
And then
the next thing you realize you're like,
I just spent like 10 minutes, you know,
thinking about something that most people
will never have to like think about
and you know, like it's, and then you have
all this extra time like, yeah, it makes,
well that's why people
look down on Americans.
They look down in Americans is where
supposedly at the peak of the abundance
pyramid right now we're
the most ridiculous as far
as our consumption and our
attitude towards consumerism and
material possessions that we eclipse.
We eclipse the rest of the world and our
ridiculousness and then as evidence of
that we provide to this reality television
culture that is sweeping the nation
and it's just more and more ridiculous
attention focused on people that are
completely undeserving of
it and well why is that?
Why is that coming from America and well
most likely because we're the ones with
the most guns were the biggest bullies.
Whether they're the ones who control them,
the the,
the military aspect of the
majority of the country,
the majority of the world rather.
And because of that we the people that
sit here in the balls of the Dick,
that's fucking the world we are,
we're weak or we're soft,
we're weak bitches.
That's why we appreciate character.
We appreciate when someone,
we appreciate survivorman which used to
be like everyday life a hundred years
ago.
We appreciate the idea that as well,
he goes to the fucking
jungle for seven days.
People live in the jungle all year
round. Okay. That's their life.
Like we are so weak that like a day
without food is what did you do?
But that's most of the world has.
There's many days where you're not going
to find something to eat and you're
going to get desperate and then you're
going to get some ingenuity together to
find something to fucking eat.
Right.
And that's how people survive to get this
far along the evolutionary food chain
in the first place. Right. Yoshi,
which your ass eating,
the reason why you eating ass,
cause you don't have to go out
there and fish for a living.
I mean Yoshi loves salad.
You know if you were out there catching
salmon all day to try to feed your
family in Alaska Souplantation
pasta salad,
every all you can eat pass other
favorite and personally I
watched those shows as in Alaska
where they di they build fish wheels.
It's the these,
this is all these shows where these people
live in Alaska and they just live off
the land and most of them don't
have any jobs. They just hunting,
farming and catching fish.
And then they huddle in for the winter
while they developed this thing called a
fish wheel and they make it out
of logs and it's huge like net,
like thing that just
spins with the current.
It keeps rolling and as it rolls it just
scoops fish out of the water and drown
them into a bucket.
It's really wild.
It's ingenious because they invented
this up there independently in Alaska
hunting well hundreds of years ago,
like who knows when the invention of the
fish wheel was. Might've been decades,
whatever. What the fuck do I
know? Alaskan historian? No,
but I'm going there with Ari Shaffir.
We're going there. This spread.
Check this out.
Joe Settled Down Anchorage.
We're on our way to
figuring out how to do this.
We're going to do this on the day
where you guys have the most salmon,
whatever that part of the year is because
Ari and I are going to do one show and
then go salmon.
Definitely figure out when the,
like that fishing season is or when
it's close to the end because that trip,
the vice showed the thumbs up when
I hitchhiked from Tijuana to Alaska.
When we got to Alaska.
This,
do you think that they would
have hot strippers and Alaska?
I would assume that if I was a stripper
and I wanted to make some real money and
evolves ambitious,
I would fly to where there's no
checks and that's where Alaska is.
This is what her ex or this is what
happens in Alaska. Ruthless bitches,
these girls,
these ruthless bitches that are smart
and ambitious and willing to go to
place where you could freeze to death.
You know these guys,
they go out on the boats were months,
right?
And then they catch all these like
crazy fish and crabs and whatever.
And then they come back and they get
paid like 20 grand cash or whatever.
And then what do they do? They go straight
to the Strip club. So these girls,
they figure it out to go to, you know,
a strip club in anchorage or whatever.
And so when I went,
the chicks are like the hottest chicks
ever and none of them are from Alaska.
They just flew in for fishing season.
Fucking
mercenaries. Mercenaries. Oh, I love it.
I love that human ingenuity, man. That's
figuring out the fish wheel. They,
these bitches invented official wheel.
They're like,
why are we wasting our time in Bismarck,
South Dakota?
We can't make a Nicole when you can find
out Alaska and these motherfuckers have
money and they're horny
as shit and you just go,
how many of those goes turn tricks?
Uh,
I have no idea. They probably don't have
to. Yeah. I mean these guys are like,
they're just,
they've just been around fish and other
men on a little tiny boat for like months
jeans on. They probably
shoot, right? Yeah.
They got those slickers on
and they're shooting pants.
They were like thick rubber and whatever.
I couldn't imagine what it's like to be
on a boat from months with a bunch of
dudes unless you were gay because the
eye for this day. But the idea of no,
no sex at all for months and months
at a time. Why am I doing this? Oh,
because I'm going to catch crabs
can get the fuck outta here.
I'm not catching it.
I don't have that kind of time.
Hey Joe, let me ask you.
Um, I, I was watching, uh,
the DMT experience on Netflix and you
were the DMT, the spirit molecule.
Yeah. Yeah. So you've
done it before. Oh yeah.
Like are you done with it
or you keep doing it? Um,
the real problem, that
discussion, okay. Is that DMT is,
I did it for the first last
year incredibly illegal.
And when you start talking about
continuing to do it, then people go, well,
where are you getting this? Right,
right, right. If anybody finds anybody,
it just became illegal.
Right now it's been illegal for a,
was made illegal in the sweeping act of,
I think it was 1970
[inaudible] psychedelic sacked.
But what's interesting
is that five Meo DMT,
which is
well, just as powerful.
I think gram for gram,
it's more potent than n and dimethyl
tree DMT is dimethyltryptamine this five
meo shit used to be legal.
We used to buy it on the Internet.
He's feel a biologic up
bucket of it for like it was,
it wasn't that much and you only need
like a pinch of that stuff and you get
blasted to the center of the university.
So while marijuana was
illegal or a good order,
DMT online,
like the first time I did DMT,
I did five meo and I did it with a bunch
of friends and one of them ordered it
online,
he ordered it,
he brought her over my house and he had
like a fucking container, this shit.
And we're like, where'd you get
this? He goes, I got it online work,
you could just buy it
online and is it real?
And he smoked it and got blasted to the
center of the universe. And I was like,
okay,
am I next?
And we all sat around on my couch and I
had a remote control for the lights and
we would hit it and then there was like
four of us in the room. It would hit it.
And then, um, when the
guy took a hit, boom,
I would hit the lights and
the lights would go off.
And like 10 minutes later the next dude
would hit it. Well, it was pretty intense.
It was a really a unique experience.
How long does it last? No.
More than like 10 minutes.
Yeah, five minutes. No,
I have not done that, but I'm going
with the, well, we made plans to go.
Dennis Mckenna wants to take, you should
take this. Go with you. I'll take you.
I want to go. Yo. Dave did it. Where would
you do it, Yoshi? If you go out, we'll do.
Okay. Were, were you going to let us film
it all? Well, you want to be with us.
We'll film it. Yes, please.
You'll be a part of it. Fun.
I had never done drugs my entire life.
I'm 36 I had never done it.
Might want to come with us. Were
you going to go? I don't know.
I think we're going to go to Peru.
I went to Columbia to do it.
Yeah.
The the selling point for me was the guy
that was like my therapist at the time.
It was like, he's like, I
could tell you are like,
you will have a very short attention
span. You get like, you know,
bored with things very easily.
Like you know,
we could make some progress with you just
through like normal therapy and this,
these kinds of things
over the course of years.
Or you can have 10 years of psychotherapy
and one night where you experience
like all these things. And I was
like, yeah, what? What does that,
and he's told me it was Iowasca so
then I went to do it in the jungle in
Columbia with him and it was exactly that.
I mean it was like completely
like life changing and therapeutic
Iowasca is a,
an elastic active hours.
No, it lasted like, well,
I had never done anything so it lasted
for me more than any of the other,
other people there.
But yeah,
I mean fuck if you took
Yoshi all this fucking
darkness inside of him, maybe
curious age, you know, I know Yoshi,
I think Yoshi is a beautiful person.
He is a beautiful person.
He had some bad circumstances as a
young man and he reacted to those
circumstances. But outside of
that, he's a great guy. But I,
when I see Yoshi,
I see a guy who was born into a situation
that he had no control over and he
reacted accordingly. Right? The,
the idea of a Iosco being,
um,
like a one day fix it,
it's kind of tricky, right?
Because it might not fix you.
It might just freaky the fuck out and
bring you back to the drawing board and,
and cause psychological state
instability. Also. I'm really dumb.
Can you explain to me like, I don't
know exactly what it is. Okay. Um,
DMT is dimethyltryptamine and it's the,
it's produced in a bunch
of different organs.
We know that the liver produces it,
the lungs produce it.
They believe it's also produced by the
brain in a gland called the pineal gland.
The evidence for that is disputed.
It's kind of more anecdotal than anything,
but in eastern mysticism,
like all of the images of the third
eye or that, that is the pineal gland.
Like if you see like all
these different like um, uh,
like deities with the gland,
third eye,
the chemical I think they say is produced
when you dream and then when you're
born and when you die. Well,
during heavy rem sleep,
they believe your brain produces more of
it and they also believe that it might
be responsible for alien abductions.
There's a lot of theories about that
because DMT is produced during rem sleep
and most of the alien abduction
experiences occur at night.
And the idea as well,
the will,
you're saying these people are dreaming
but they know it really happened. No,
I'm saying it doesn't mean either or
just because they're having these crazy
fucked up experiences doesn't mean that
crazy fucked up experiences isn't a
reality.
It just might be an ethereal reality
and some alternative dimension and it's
only accessible through chemicals
and that is a possibility.
The possibility that everything
you experience, look,
even if you experience a dream that's
profound, it's still an experience.
What is happening in that dream that
becomes so profound that you sort of see
things in a different way. You're having
some sort of an experience, you're,
you're taking in information,
there's no unique ones and Zeros that
are entering into your mind that are
allowing you to form a new
version of the world. Well, the,
when the drug experience under DMT,
which is again the,
or you know, the, the quicker
acting form of viral Alaska, the,
they know the act of contents
and I osca whatever that is,
is a very potent experience.
Real or not, it's silly to judge,
right. The idea that you can't hit
it with a hammer, so it's not real.
You can't put it on a scale.
So it's not real. Yeah.
Measure it with a ruler to me is why it
was life changing because I could have a
dream and I'll be like,
oh,
I felt like I just dreamt that I flew.
Right. Yeah. But like Joe saying,
this thing makes you actually feel
like you had just flown like, like,
so I'll ask him, make it's the same thing.
Well, you know, it's like people say,
well,
it wasn't real.
It doesn't matter.
It's exactly the same as if it was real.
Let's be very scientific here.
Let's say you were having a hallucination
and that hallucination lasted one hour
and in that one hour,
this chemical perturbed your normal sense
of visual stimulation and the input to
the mind and it gave you a distorted
perception of reality, right?
And then let's say,
um,
so let's say that's option a and then
let's say option B is you took a magic
fairy dust that brought you to an
enchanted land that couldn't have possibly
been accessed without it.
And in that world you communicated with
impossibly intelligent entities that
broke down the universe for you in a way
that you could understand in your brief
time there. And then let's look
at those two things and say,
regardless of which one is true,
they both achieve the exact same result.
You have the exact same experience,
whether it's,
whether it's preturbing your sense of
visual input to the mind or whether it's
you really go to a magic fairy land
and communicate with God, right?
The same thing happens.
You can make noises with your mouth
and use the cultural context of written
language and historical reference to sort
of like put it in a position where you
can explain it to a group of people
that are not going to make fun of you.
But the reality of it is all
culture aside, all language aside,
all preconceived notions aside, you're
having the same fucking experience. So,
so it was it life changing for you
though? I got a tattoo and I'm like, Whoa,
that's a DMT molecule right there. All
right. Aside from the Tattoo was nothing.
Oh, changed the way I look at
the whole universe. Yeah, me too.
I sort of understand. Um, after, I mean,
I understand first of all that I don't
really understand any of it, right.
But I understand after
I did it that, um, uh,
my whole idea of the world that I had
used as a reference that I use is like,
this is this and this is that and this
is the banking system and this is the
government.
It became ridiculous.
It all became ridiculous.
And the idea that this could exist
and I couldn't know about it. Right.
And that could have been living my
life. It became infant tile, the whole,
the universe became infant,
toddler, everything, sex, money,
driving it to all be, I mean you're taking
the words right out of my mind. Both.
I mean it's, it just shows
you the ridiculous, it's,
it was completely life changing for me.
But here's the danger in it I think is
when I start going off on him because I
didn't get a tattoo of it.
But I'm super passionate about about it
now because it did like completely like
alter my vision of how I see things is
I started sound like a maniac when I
started talking about it too much to my
where and when you start talking about
it and get super passionate about it,
you don't sound crazy.
But then I'm aware of the
perception of like, oh people,
Dave sounds fucking
like a maniac and crazy.
And he was talking about
this weird drug and then it,
and then the thing about it is I did it
in Columbia with like 20 other people
who are these 20 other people?
You know,
it was like this trip
arranged trip and it's like,
it's exactly who you thought they were
like weird hippie type people. You know,
the fact that this thing exists and that
it only attracts these like we're like
dreadlocked white people.
Fringy people when if
the right people did it,
basically I think everyone should do it.
But if the right people that,
that didn't hear it in all, man,
that sounds like fucking crazy,
like hippy bullshit, you know,
it, it could like literally
like change the world.
Like we could change the consciousness
of the whole plan. Really could.
And that's that it sounds stupid,
especially coming from me because my
credibility is limited me to fear factor.
And I do cage fighting commentary and
then I do a podcast while under the
influence of illegal drug. So it's
like, look at all those equation.
Only illegal federally. Um, why did
you have to go to jungle though?
Why can't you just cause it's
illegal in the United States.
I didn't even know that schedule one.
It is one of the most illegal drugs
in the world along with marijuana,
which by the way, the idea of scheduling
one is that it has no medical use,
which is hilarious because there is
medical marijuana approved in California.
It's been proved beyond a shadow of a
doubt that it helps in a lot of different
areas.
It helps people with cancer,
helps people going through chemo
to get their appetite back.
And that was people with glaucoma
by reducing interocular pressure,
it helps people with add the idea that
there's no medical benefits of it just
because it's not, I mean, and
then they make a pill for it.
They make fucking that THC pill
that they uh, I don't know.
Whatever the fuck it's called.
I didn't want to say it cause I
don't want anybody to buy it. Right.
Cause it's horse shit. You know,
they make like a synthetic THC pill,
which doesn't have nearly the
effects of just edible cannabis.
That's something that we were talking
about before the show where it's like,
brownies, fuck you up. They don't
just fuck you up because bus,
we'd fucks you up. They fuck
you up. Because when you eat it,
he produces a completely
different chemical in your
body. You're, when marijuana,
when THC is consumed in an edible form,
it produces something called
11 hydroxy metabolite, right?
Which is like five times more
psychoactive than THC. Well, I believe it.
Yeah. You know why that weird feeling
that you get when you eat a Brownie.
But I will never forget this man.
My friend Brent had a,
Brett rather had a Holla, had, uh,
a company when he was trying to do,
when the medical marijuana
movement first started,
he had this company who's doing,
was making THC pills. Right?
And I don't know what he did to fucking
get this stuff into a pill form,
but he had, this is my strong
one and this is my medium one.
Or if you're gonna take the medium
one, only take one. Right? Like, well,
why do you have a strong
one? He goes, I don't know.
Eddie Bravo takes both of them.
He takes,
he takes at least if you took two strong,
either took two strong ones or
two medium ones, whatever he did,
I took one right and maybe an hour and a
half later I was the most uncomfortable
I have ever been in my entire life
where I was so terrified of everything.
The eye, well, I was looking at people
and they became two dimensional,
but that was like seeing their souls like
peeking behind while they were talking
to me. I mean it became
like incredibly psychedelic,
like way more psychedelic than weed and
I didn't understand about the 11 hydroxy
metabolite thing then.
But I talked to my friend Todd Mccormick
who just medical marijuana activist and
a professional natural deodorant user
at Brown and I'm a brilliant guy,
brilliant, brilliant guy. When it
comes to medical marijuana, he's,
he actually did time.
It was like one of the first guys to do
time for medical in California because
they wouldn't let him use the term
medical marijuana even though he was
operating under state law or when
they bring you to court. Right.
Because it's a federal trial,
right?
You don't even allow you to use the
term medical marijuana that term.
You can't say it in court. What do you
say you'd go to jail. So what do you say?
You got to say I grew marijuana and
sold it. Oh. And then they say, well,
you're a criminal. And then
he goes, uh, he said, well,
I was operating in the state lost shut up.
You can't bring up state law and a
federal court. It's an incredible, and he,
and he, um, he wound up doing time,
but he's the perfect person. He's like,
I can always call him. And He, you know,
he's a grower so I can call them up.
And I go, well, what does that and
why, why the fuck am I getting so high?
And it goes, oh, you got this, you got to
understand. Do you smoke weed everyday?
No,
but I don't like to do anything every day.
I don't think you should do anything
every day. But when you do do smoke,
I don't smoke weed or any of that stuff.
Even eat every day.
I like taking days off of eating
fast and stuff. Not even fast.
I just drink water and take a day off and
eating. I've done that before. You know,
it's like the ID. Here's my
problem with fasting. My same,
the same problem I have with
healing. Right? You know,
like what are you talking about?
I'm a healer. Shut the fuck up.
You're not a healer. Stop. You might give
good massages or not a fucking healer.
You crazy bitch. I have
his new firm. I was,
I just started getting rolfing done.
Know what rolfing done.
It's like super painful, deep
tissue massage. And I, uh,
I read a bunch of different websites.
I was looking for someone that
does w Rolfing, the La area,
and I read this one lady's
bio and it was like,
I always knew from the moment I was a
child that I had natural healing and this
is what I'm talking about,
Joe, all this shit that like
you, like, that's good shit,
but only attracts like weird NATO's.
Yeah. Well, because you know,
there's a lot of fuckery in the world.
There's a lot of fuckery psychics.
You at least jerk off everyday
though, right? Me Or you
take days off. I'm taking,
I've taken many days off.
I never take it no more than 30 in a row,
but I'm a hard worker
when it comes to that.
I did that once for a
website project. What, how,
how has the longest it took 30
days off. Well, it was ridiculous.
We just like leaking everywhere.
I was getting bonus from hugs,
hugs full on boner.
Boner hubs are pretty fantastic.
It was amazing. I was like, wow.
Am when I first came to La, I uh,
I had a girlfriend in
New York and uh, we, uh,
we were kind of like on the outs when I
first moved to La and I was figuring out
whether or not I should move her in with
me and bring her out here and whatever.
And I was out here working on a TV show
for like two weeks and with by myself
living in the Oak Woods apartment complex
and I was on the set and this girl,
she said something the girl was working
with and we laughed and she said, Oh,
give me a hug,
and she gave me this big giant hug and
you came in through her belly button. Nah,
man, I, I got her pregnant. I just,
the hug felt so good. I was like,
I got, I was like, I was at,
I was on empty and I pulled into the
gas station and she filled me out. By
then I realized like as a human
being at that point in my,
I was like in my twenties I was
still pretty fucking stupid,
but I realize as a human
being that the human touch is,
it's not just a luxury that it's a staple.
It's a staple for a mental management and
then if you don't have someone in your
life, you don't have loving
people in your life. It's not a,
it's not a I inconvenience.
Convenience. It's like it's unhealthy.
It's bad for your body. It's, there's a,
there was a, there was something going on.
And again,
and what,
you can't measure it in the fucking
milligrams of vitamin C or Caffeine or
alcohol there, but there was a
reaction in my body that was very real.
When that girl hugged me,
I felt so much better.
And I'll never forget that
because I'm like, okay,
well I have to realize
that this is a real,
this is something isn't one more thing
that we can't measure in conventional
terms, but that it actually
exists and it's tangible and
it's a fact. Well, I mean,
I come from a family of huge
hookers, like, that's awesome.
I parents hug the shit out of me.
That's very unusual.
My Dad kisses me on my mouth. That's
beautiful. Uh, no tongue or tongue,
sometimes a little bit of tone,
especially after whiskey breath. Right.
And then in the time that I met Yoshi,
you know, have you ever tried like,
you know, I hug all my friends. This is
the most awkward guy ever. He's like, Yo,
shell the title.
But he's like,
alright,
alright.
Jesus, that lazy gentleman was
a gas moment in our podcast.
Just came in his pants and
we've had gay be blond.
We had gay people on confirmed. You
know what? I don't think we have.
You make so much more sense then we
need to get a a gay representation. Oh,
by the way, we're going to have Melissa
Etheridge on the podcast. Whoa. Yeah.
Melissa Ashridge actually asked to be
on the podcast. Publicists content out.
I hope she doesn't yell at me for
my cartoonish portrayal of lesbian.
That's fine. This isn't punishment.
I hope she actually likes it.
I like it as beans. She might not be.
This might not be a friendly visit.
I'm just kidding, but we need more gay
representation on this podcast. She's gay.
She's a lesbian.
It's different.
I always trip on the word gay. Anyway,
look at all uncomfortable. It looks good.
It looks like you just check
to see if he has a boner.
You guys chose Yo. She's good
man. No, he's a great guy.
He's just very awkward with human
[inaudible]. She had an awkward awkward,
just not me, but that's not
a very common thing in Japan.
You don't talk about Asians
don't have your, your reality,
your situation like your family,
like you don't want to talk about though.
I talked to him.
Everything you tell everybody in the
whole story what you did and why you can't
go back to Japan. No, I could
go back. I just can't get out.
You can't get out once you go back.
I would imagine so.
There's probably why that there's
probably like a criminal record tell.
It's a little different because tell
everybody what happened if you want it to
you. I mean this is an interesting
story. The best story ever. Well,
if you want to listen, not
a problem at all. Okay.
That's the only reason why I brought
this up is because I know you're pretty
adamant about expressing
yourself all the time.
I will say before I finished, I
started the story that uh, Dave,
what's the rest are in Japan September
of 2003 in the same week I was in jail in
La County. So I guess we were
meant to meet each other,
but they are part of 10 years ago. Set
this coming September, we're in jail. Oh,
someone sounds like
stalker.
That's exactly what I would send an email
if I was trying to get them to get me
pregnant. So what's
your, tell us your story.
So I got an email in August,
2003 from my cousin.
Basically my writing skill
in Japanese isn't that good.
So he wrote it in English. He basically
could roll pop up dead. That's a nice one.
Dead. My father was dead, but they
didn't know how to write in English.
So that's the only thing they will.
And I called them and find out
my dad supposedly killed himself.
So wedding couple of days I flew back
to Japan and find out what happened
because I saw him six months
before, early 2003. Um,
I find out that my step mother was
cheating on my dad before marriage,
during marriage. And they're trying to,
they're in process getting divorced,
but my dad killed himself later one.
We don't know for sure.
He commit suicide or my step have
something to do with his death.
We don't know. But, um, during the
funeral I still, my step mother killed.
You think she killed? I think so. Why do
you think that? The more I hear the story,
she sounds like the most, like my
cousins, older brother in Korea,
she was living in Korea. My
stepmother, so my cousins,
older brother lives in Korea,
their version FBI,
they checked the background and my
stepmother flew in the day before.
The last time they saw my dad alive.
Doesn't mean that he killed her,
but that she lied. She killed him. Yeah.
She said that she was in Japan the whole
time and we find out later why she lied.
She lied about that. Well, she
lied about that. That's that,
that kind of guilt lying about where
you were very suspicious. Yeah.
So it doesn't mean she did it
die. How did he die? Um, hanging.
So I went to police station,
saw the picture,
and he was in the hot sun for
like two weeks. So he was dark.
I mean, he looked like he was hanging
outside, inside, but that summertime,
Japan is so hot and humid,
a decomposing. This is,
this is how I met Yoshi told us.
What was the joke?
It was the darkest joke I've ever
heard in my life. What did I say?
Hi. I'm a little high. You're a little
[inaudible] told the joke. It's so fun.
It's not a joke. I just say, you know,
he was darker than a nigger or whatever,
but oh yo,
that is not a dark joke
or even a good one.
But the racial slurs darker
than Bobby Lee's balls. Yes.
So Bobby Lehan dark balls,
black balls. The, I can't have,
I can't approve that. That joke. Do you
don't say that on stage do. Yeah, he did.
He did. I was like, this guy's
crazy. He's like, that's ridiculous.
That's how you ended
your act or something.
That's a good way to get your
ass kicked. Not yet. But um,
but basically he had been
hanging and he turned black,
so he was hanging and basically the heat
of the house just kind of slowly cooked
him. Yeah. I mean, I saw the
picture, the cop told me,
I highly recommend you don't look at the
picture, but I needed to see, you know,
because after his death,
my family farm,
he told me that all the horrible
things that we were have.
So do you think that she could have
possibly driven him to do that?
That for sure. 100% yeah. Yeah. She
lived hundreds of thousands of dead.
And He, she told my dad that she
brought one of her cousin from Korea.
We laid on find out it was her, her the
whole time. So while my dad was working,
she was fucking this guy pretending
to be her cousin, whatever.
Just the whole humiliation debt and all
this stuff. And like, was she younger?
10 years younger, but this, are you
sure she wasn't just fucking her cousin.
This is why a guy like David
should be afraid of marriage. Okay.
Never ever,
never fuck someone where you're confused
as to why they're fucking you or never.
But then
the reality is,
and the natural law world,
you shouldn't get laid. Brian,
you should get your shit
together first. But so, so,
so that happens when you do that man,
people start to resent.
You ever see like a famous dude with a
trophy wife and the trophy wife fucking
hates being there, you know? And you see
that, that that's uh, that's a sketchy
situation.
Yeah.
I watched this dude and a watched his
wife yelled at him and shit and he's like,
uh,
like this sort of minuscule famous guy.
He's a small guy and the
wife was yelling at him,
giving him a hard time and he had just,
he just absorbed it and dealt
with it and it was really,
it really fucked me up cause this guy's
really famous and I was doing, man,
why are you in this prison abuse you,
this is fucking shitty person in
your life is treating you like that.
Why? Because she's not impressed
with you. Like what is it?
I'll tell you why some people wait a
hundred and fucking 30 pounds and she was
six foot tall and hot as fuck and she
really wanted to get fucked by giant black
guy.
Mandingo giant Mandingo or
cause and maybe like when a guy,
when the guy is an old guy and he's got
this hot young chippy and there was no
washes with them. Yeah. She's
fucking stealing from you man. Yeah.
So what happened?
So I went back to the funeral and um,
somehow she was,
she didn't know my temperament because
my dad's a very kind and nice person.
He's never hit me before, but
I have temperament from my
mother. She was, you know,
she was typical Korean women
varies, uh, aggressive, you know.
So I caught her at the funeral by herself,
uh,
preparing to funeral thing for my dad.
Right. It was like way up a hill. Yeah.
Way Up in the hill, rest of the family
of down the hill and parking lot.
They didn't know what's going on.
So basically I went up there with my
aunt and my aunt's soul, my stepmother,
and she goes, you kill my fucking
brother. You fucking bitch. He leaves.
It was me and her and everyone knows at
this point that she was cheating on him
the whole time. Oh yeah. Everybody
knows that. She though this all.
She even tried to poison my dad. So next
thing you know, she tried to poison.
They took the sample way
in all those Korean dish,
Kimchi or whatever she brought from Korea.
My Dad kept getting sick so they took
all the food from refrigerator at some
medical lab.
They check and there was a poison in a
dish when your stomach is poisoning his
Kimchi and hitting on and cheating on him
and the whole family knows and she has
the fucking balls to go to the funeral.
When she was playing this thing,
she didn't know anything about me and
her older sister has a reputation of
Marion, bunch of guy and they all
tie in a mysterious circumstances,
have a history.
They have a history of that.
Her older sister does this fucking thing.
This sounds like it's crazy. It's
fucking insane. So my aunts are,
you fucking beg you kill my brother.
She left and then 10 seconds later I just
started running over and just beating
the shit out of her and I grabbed back
of her head and start punching their face
for a long time and put her
in. She's unconscious. No,
but she was shocked because she didn't
know I had an inmate to do that and I was
a little surprised because I didn't
plan to do that. I was angry,
but I didn't take, she was dumb enough to
be separated by the rest of her family,
but she was arrest. Gosh, who? She
was by herself. You are by herself.
No one's anywhere near that.
No one near.
And instead of grabbing her back of her
head and just started beating her face
in stop and uh,
put on her ground and it's not stumping
be turning or legs, eyeball was dumped.
Her Pussy. Yeah, stomach and her face,
her eyeball is about to come out.
I was stamping her face like
I have to five or six times.
I heard some lady that work
at the cemetery scream,
that's when I kinda just stomping
on this lady and started screaming.
So how much damage did you do to her?
I think if I did it,
like my cousin called me and like
week later and he was actually,
he was laughing on the phone like,
yeah, if you did it for another menu,
probably killed her,
whatever.
She ended up going to hospital for
like two and a half, three months,
but that's snapped him out of it.
The lady screaming.
So then he ran back down the
hill. That's true. And then like,
like everyone's like
what the fuck's going on?
And he like grabbed his cousin's
car keys. No, no, no. Yes.
I went down and uh,
my stepmother's nephew was walking up the
stairs. He didn't know what's going on.
So I started coming down and he
doesn't know what's going on.
And so I figured by then
I already beat one person.
What difference does it make if I, so
his guy goes, people, this funeral was,
how long after Japan?
Why like when you got off the plane and
went straight to the funeral, right?
A day after? Yeah. So
this guy gets the Japan,
goes to a funeral and then just
starts punching people and then like,
so you attacked him as well?
For what reason?
Just because I feel related to her,
related to her and like what difference
does it make if I think everybody at
this point? Yeah. It's like
porn stars. Like what difference
does it make you feel?
What?
Fuck one hooker or 500 at once you do one.
It's really interesting that you're using
attempted murder and connecting it to
gang bang. Oh, Yoshi kills
hookers all the time now
and kills him with his aides.
So the animal ate at a boy.
So I went down the stairs, I
saw him, I sucker punch him.
He doesn't know what's going on. Oh
my God. And there was a little, uh,
you feel bad for that? No, not at all.
But he, I wish I want to do with it.
I know I was just angry with her
and her family. Right. But I mean,
her family is just people.
Yeah. You know, I mean,
you don't feel bad fat of poisoning
poisonous Pete. Well, you know,
I mean maybe they don't know what the
fuck the sister and her dad at the time.
I didn't,
I wasn't really rationale.
It was just so I sucker punching.
He went down and most of these eight,
I'm six foot one.
Most of these people are
like five one five, two.
So even though I'm not a
physically imposing in America,
I'm pretty big in Japan.
You're kicking ass in jail.
Um,
Anderson Silva when it comes to
fighting and beating up old women,
but so how old was she when you
did this to her? 55 or something.
Oh, Holy Shit. She killed his dad,
man. Oh, I understand. Listen,
there's no [inaudible] I lost my fucking
mind. Listen, I would have killed her. I,
if I, if I'm stomping on a check
for five times, she's dead.
I don't know how the fuck your
pussy stomps allowed her to live.
So he knocks the,
knocks the nephew out.
I got this little is not something
to joke about, by the way,
ladies and gentlemen. You're
right. If your outrage
listening to this, you're like,
I can't believe he just got that little
mallet where Buddhist scope to water to
clean that cemetery. I grabbed
that stuff, just beat him one.
But they had a couple of times ran
down the parking lot and it's so the my
stepmother's older sister and her and
her husband and then I started s sucker
punch him too. It's punching everybody.
Yeah. Punchbowl endurance at this point.
You're getting winded. Yeah. I wish I
would have stretched before that fight,
but I didn't plan,
it wasn't planning itself.
I don't know anything by my short,
I don't know any of that stuff.
It was unplanned was
beat all these people.
But how do you get out of the country?
Uh, like Syria. My Shit, Mike,
my aunt Yoshi, she's the only one
when he started finding me back,
she's the one, she had a cancer brain
cancer actually, but she's the one that,
you know, uh, interrupt a fight, sub
punching him and just told me to leave.
And I told my cousin dragged me out of
there and he wasn't sure cause he went to,
so you punched them too? No, no, no, no.
If I think he hesitated because he doesn't
want to a somebody who did criminal
acts,
but he's smaller than I am.
So if you don't think I'm going
to beat the shit out of it.
Well we got in his car,
he's dry me out of there and I
went to all second international.
He just got to Japan.
Yeah, like a day before.
And then he went and beat
everyone up and then he's hiding.
You got right to the airport? I grabbed
his cell phone and call the airlines,
changed my flight.
I'm praying there's another flight within
four hours and there just happened to
be one in four hours.
So I went over there.
But that was the longest full hours
airport because I figure she'll call the
police what happened had
they not call the police.
It never even occurred to them because
they were so worried about her.
They went to hospital, whether it
probably didn't know where you went.
They figured out. They figured out was
hiding somebody, one of my cousin's house.
Do you think that they knew that she was
guilty too, or everybody knows? She said,
how did you find out it was your
aunt that told you, right? Yeah.
It was her trying to poison
him. Huh? Yeah. Your aunt
told you, what did she say?
They have a medical record
in this whole time. Yeah,
but it doesn't mean she tried to kill him.
Oh No.
She tried to kill him because
of the poisoning though.
That's pretty definitive.
Yeah. And they had a medical lab. Uh, I
don't know how they figured out poisoned,
but they took it to lab. Ever
Eat Kimchi at Yoshi, his house,
he keeps his daddy's Kimchi in general
is pretty strong and I love Kimchi,
Kimchi at Yoshi cells and it tastes
a little weird. Don't eat that shit.
Damn Dude. So you escaped Japan? Yeah.
And the other criminal charges pressed
against you. Here's a weird thing.
Mostly comps in Japan doing or be a part
of like family dispute with technical.
She's still my family. So whenever
there's a family at each birthday, rather,
there's even a fucking head
stomping. Well, generally speaking,
but, um, I don't want to go back to
Japan to find out. So remember you,
and I think Jody's, it does ask me and
like the goal, but you're in translate.
I would love to do it, but I was
little war. Maybe soon as I land,
there's a wrecker of it and put me in
jail. They could be right. There might be,
but most likely I can't get out.
Dave cannot get in.
Those are two different things.
Can you not get in? I went to jail.
There are a few years ago.
What'd you go to jail,
therefore I beat up a undercover
security guard. What happened? Well,
it's sort of, it's sort of
like Yoshi said, I'm not a huge
guy over here,
but over there,
like I'm sort of the Anderson
Silva of what happened over there.
Uh, you know, it's,
I could talk about this for like
hours and hours, but basically I,
I in much of the same way
where I helped, uh, you know,
the old people dinner
during the earthquake,
turn their gas off and then went
looting, like have a, you know,
I had a troubled past
where, you know, beef,
this is before I got like
seriously into gambling.
Like I spent most of
my childhood just like,
just like fighting and getting into all
kinds of trouble and doing like small
time criminal kind of
activities and stuff.
And so when I went to Japan where it
was like the society based on like honor
and like, you know, the light turns
red and then everyone stops walking.
And I was like, Whoa,
this is fucking crazy.
Like they like don't even have locks on
their bicycles because who would steal a
bike that's not your property?
Like it's crazy.
Like you could literally go to Japan
and just get on someone's biking. Just,
I was like, this is fucking nuts. So
that's what I did. I'd go to Japan,
I'd steal some guy's bike
and I'd go out all night,
spray painting graffiti
on everything cause like,
and I would just do it in broad daylight,
like no one would stop me, you know?
And then at the end of the day I just go
bring the bike back. And so, you know,
my art was getting a lot of
recognition out there at the time.
So I was going out there like once a year,
twice a year,
no stealing bikes, stealing bikes through
graffiti, stealing shit. Like just,
just causing, you know, damage
and chaos in general. Right.
So, yeah, I mean
is, that's one thing when
we were in Japan, uh, some,
some guide was telling me about
like the same kind of thing.
Like you could tell these girls anything,
they'll believe you
cause more lies to them.
So like you can tell him like that you're
super famous rock stars and it kind of
felt bad about it, you know, like you felt
after Brian's fifth stories,
I'm not really iron man.
Wow. So you got arrested
for doing well? Yeah, I mean
definitely deserved. I mean it was the
best thing that could happened to me.
My life in general was getting out of
control and going to jail was probably the
best thing.
Dude, you, you guys both in
fucking awesome. Thank you
very much for doing this.
Thank you for coming down this.
I would love to do yours as well.
Let's go back and forth, back and forth
to what? A bunch of different off.
Love to have your Yoshi. Keep it together.
Okay. I think you're going to be fine.
There's a lot of people are gonna Stare
at you Wednesday night, the Ice House,
knowing that you almost
stumped a lady to death,
so it's going to be a
little bit deserved it man.
It's going to be an interesting
show Wednesday night.
Anyone who is coming out Wednesday night,
please don't be afraid to give this
guy hawk. He needs a human touch.
Murder is murder. If you saw his
face after that group hug right now,
it was very uncomfortable. He didn't
know how to accept that kind of love.
He's our drip guy. You're a great guy.
He's a good guy. He's a great guy.
He just needs a lot more hugs.
Did we didn't even get to your
whole crazy fucking story.
The whole Facebook mural story. I'll
come. I'll come back on anytime.
You won't do it again man. Let's
do it again. Let's do it again in
February. You want to do it
again in February? Anytime man.
Done and we'll do yours. Barney
one comma mean Devi. Okay,
well you guys are invited to
d a s a dotcom. Oh my. I don't know
if we're going to get on iTunes,
so just go to there to
check it out on iTunes. A Lt
probably. You can get away. You can
do it. Yeah, especially the audio.
They'll allow anything.
It's essentially the imagination.
You're just talking about things.
You're not sure.
You can't show pornographic
images and a video iPod thing.
Easily hybrid of all of Yo, she's
bought wholesale. It's, yeah, no,
don't show yo she's home because
it's just too tempting. Again,
like his gay porn or
it's training and stuff.
It might drag you over to the dark side.
Yo,
she would tempt you with
this black hole of butthole.
Well, you guys are filming. You guys
are filming this whole show, right?
On our podcast we have one camera and
it's just pointed at Oscars. Pussy.
That's hilarious. It's like you want to
see how did you, how did you meet her?
How did you guys become friends? This
guy, he just became my buddy. Well it's,
it's like the thing you were saying about
the cock hold and like watching black
guys,
like I've talked about this before,
but basically if you're
a guy and your Asian,
the only place you are in American
porn is, is gay and the bottom,
there's not one Asian male
porn star in straight porn.
So just the one now except for one now,
which was that movie.
So after I got to know Yoshi and you know,
knowing what a degenerate he is,
he's like,
hey Dave,
they're filming the first Asian American
porn where the whole cast is Asian.
And I was like, Whoa, that's pretty like
groundbreaking, you know, there's no like,
like it's gay to know what I
guess when you jerk off to porn,
like I've watched so much porn, I could
recognize the guy's penis now about that.
Yeah. That's pretty North Homo. Exactly.
Exactly. And you know, you seen,
there's not that many guys, so you
start to recognize the guys. Yeah.
So can you name a Asian male porn
star? Yeah, there isn't any. Right.
So Yoshi told me about it and
then we went, yeah, we went,
I went to the set of the,
the first and it was,
it was based on a weird
Japanese poet or someone,
some chick that like cuts off her lover's
penis or something. It was very hard.
Yeah. Fist to the nuts star
and also was the star in that.
So we hit it off right away. And uh,
yeah, that's how I met also through Yoshi.
And that was like the first time that
was the first, like she just got married.
Yeah. She just got
married. Dude, trust me.
That's all I kind of a deal is that well,
it's to another porn star. Yeah. So,
uh, okay. But, uh, you know, she was the,
she was one of the first like women
that I met that I was like genuinely
interested in after my seven
year long relationship.
So I met her on that set.
And then I'm like,
this chick is fucking Rad.
Like she'll just like talk about anything
and how she has to like wash your
butthole out and it's just like not
in a gross way and it's very to meet
someone that's like so open and honest
about everything. She's very funny too.
Synchronicity and the,
the,
the word DVD asa when you're
doing a show with asa. Akira.
Yeah. Well, I mean it sounds like David
and asa phonetically, phonetically,
but it's actual double,
double,
double anal census sensitive artists.
So that's the website. Let me Ladies
and gentlemen, double vaginal,
double anal sensitive artist. If
you can't find it, go fuck yourself.
It's a great podcast.
We don't want you to find it.
It's one of the very few podcasts that
I actually listened to. I love it. Oh,
thanks for podcasts.
Made me hate a lot of people that I
used to not find it annoying. All right,
I'll fucking listen to their podcast
and I want to fucking throw him off a
mountain.
The story of how you first met, um,
Yoshi is one of my favorite stories.
I think it was on the first
episode of DVD Essay and just your,
your how you do his
voice isn't first nation,
so it makes the story so much better.
So we're going to bring you out of this,
but prepare for a fucking avalanche of
a hate mail from people don't like dude
stomp and women a death, especially
when they're in their 50 [inaudible].
Honestly, if anyone out there
wants to sit here and judge Yoshi,
think about if there was a person out
there that like did your family wrong and
what you would do to them,
especially kill your dad. Yeah.
I mean you don't know if she did, but at
the very least she tried the very least.
She tried to poison.
But then here's the flip side of that.
Are You mad at your dad for like
allowing a woman like that? The power,
I was really angry with him. Do you
think like, yeah, I mean he goes, well,
you're doing
by partnering up with slots is an
excellent move because much like getting
inoculation shots or protects you from
other sluts being so mystical did they
could take over your life.
You know when a,
when a girl will try to move in and like
offer you pussy to try to like control
your financial empire,
you'd be like pitch. Right.
I know where I can get some pussy stop.
We're dealing with
quantities and qualities.
We're dealing with a of a
commodities market here, right?
Yeah. I mean it's, it's,
it's unbelievable. David.
Someday you're going to find the
rancor and loves you for you. Oh girl,
a sensitive girl. The you, you're not
going to want to be with anybody. I know.
She's going to be so beautiful
and have a 12 inch penis. Oh,
and with that one.
Oh,
what y'all for the black ice black guys,
ice I c e and coincidentally you don't
find many black guys where there's black
ice. I don't know why that
is. Follow Yoshi on Twitter.
It's Yoshi Obayashi o. B. A. Y.
A. S. H. I on Twitter and David Choe,
David C. H. O. E.
You could also go to
David choe.com and uh,
and just try to buy one of his paintings.
First of all, I can't find them.
They're not for sale. And even if it did,
you don't want to spend that much money.
All right, listen, he's Outta your
league, Bitch. Deal with addicts.
Deal with ads. Thanks to onnit.com
for sponsoring our podcasts.
Go to o,
n n I t and use the code name Brogan and
you will save yourself 10% of any and
all supplements. Also, thanks to hover,
go to hover.com forward slash.
Rogen.
Please use them for all your dome robot,
robot cock.
Hold up your butt holes.
Suck my cock fatty.com all one word.
You can do this people
Yoshi, stomps vaginas. Yeah,
that's, you know that's going to be used.
Tammy, why? Why'd you do this? Dave had,
why Joe go to harvard.com forward
slash Rogan for 10% off. Yoshi, sorry,
this is very selfish. I have podcasts to
Yoshi. Didn't, that's not selfish at all.
Would it help if she did? No, Yoshi
didn't. That is really your back.
Everything's a gun. Damn play on
words. Yoshi male Wednesday night,
say Road Yoshi.
Yoshi didn't and Yoshi will be at the Ice
House in Pasadena this Wednesday night
at 10:00 PM along with uh,
Ian Edwards along with Brian Red Band
along with Adam Hunter and one of the
motherfucker that I can't remember and
maybe many more, whoever's in town,
but the idea of the ice house, I'll
call Fitzsimmons to see if he's around.
The idea of the ice house is we just
try to put on shows there where we fuck
around, have a good time. We use
it as sort of a workout room.
It's the last time I did it, I came up
with like 20 minutes a new material.
You guys, these shows are fucking
amazing. They're so fun to do.
And it's one of the best comedy
environments on the planet Earth.
It's a club that's been around
since 1960 and it's just like,
I can't say enough good things about
the staff or the the owner Bob.
He's the coolest motherfucker ever.
And to me it's really important to support
places like this because they're very
fragile. It's not a lot of
money and owning a comedy club.
And I want to help these people that
think about bailing out. All right,
I've got a desk,
squad.tv and you can pick up one of these
fucking Badass tee shirts designed by
our very own prion and there's
two different versions of it.
There's this one that is a my favorite
cat and then there's that one, which uh,
I also like the design sign but you
can't buy that one anymore so you could
probably get that shit on Ebay.
You should just make more of those,
make more of those. But the whole
point is that the point sucks.
The point sucks up right. Delicious
Syphilis Lid, written cock.
Good night folks.
We will see you tomorrow.
Most likely with the Aubrey Marcus.
I'm going to try to move some shit around
cause Arby's in town and a Rick Ross
lives here so we'll call him.
We'll make everything happen.
We are going to get our freak on one
way or another. Bitches. David Cho,
Yoshi, thanks Joe. Thanks.
Thank you guys. Yeah. Awesome.